n
[Music]
nah
n n n nah
[Music]
n
nah
[Music]
yo yo my check might check on this
glorious glorious Sunday let's see how
the levels are sounding see how we doing
out here around what's going on nice
call let's see what we got it up
Benjamin what's going on salute salute
p050 what's going on Zach Riley what's
going on how my levels s Lan Master F in
the building no doubt F gaming what's
going on JM the OG what's going on
Salute I see you thank you thank you for
the heads up Lord Bak we was rocking
last night I'm surprised you up man you
was rocking you playing that teing but I
mad
late what's Bard doing Zach Ry what's
going on Matthew Ash what's going on Dr
Strange Love what's going on salute
salute James Morrison what's up the
holies Craig hooligan on Deck Steve
what's going on yeah yeah yeah we about
to get this going about to see what's up
your attic in the building might might
be M moving around he moving and shaking
oh he's here oh okay here he
your mic is real crispy right get that
again hello hello yeah your mics are
extra powerful today I like
that no doubt so we going to see what's
going on man we got stuff going on and
uh interesting topics that's just
SI yeah have to fam salute salute yeah
that was fun last night that was a
throwback night all right y so we going
to get everybody accounted for and
around see what's going on and be right
back
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
that they can Saron up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I
got what you do stop that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoal to be your dog
thing very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that yoga
fight flame they think it's Aron up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I
Gott what you do don't stop that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you can say it I'm very spoil put to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been been a nerd never
been a loser making Vault Tron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be handable
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can Saron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on AIM check my vocals all on Twitter
but I'm anal love my city but I'm still
I
[Music]
got keep that going keep that going go
ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil put to be your dog they
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making VA
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y to Dramatical I know it's
random but I am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's sing up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting and
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to St regardless
back when you was messaging people on a
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anal love my city but I'm still by coal
I got let's Swit what did you do Don't
Stop N that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead I guess you could say that I'm
very spoil feel to be your dog they a't
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser makeing
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing that real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that yog this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the RS you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on AIM check my vocals all on Twitter
but I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still by coal I got let's switch that
what you do stop that was dop keep that
keep that going keep that going go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil to be your dog very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a got check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's switch
that up
what did you do Don't Stop N that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you can say that I'm very spoiled feel
to be your dog thing very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making vron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be hanal
they be like why you a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
the start regardless back we was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
switch
[Music]
that keep keep
keepad look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil them to be your dogs they
ain't very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault Tron with a gang of cougar
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part me being a accountable and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and make it INF flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's saring up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
started regardless back when you was
messaging people on a
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still by
coal I got let's Swit that you don't
stop n that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoil to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't here the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Fredy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be a original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting and range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
was messaging people on a check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's Swit that what you do don't stop
that was dope keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you could say that I'm very spoil feel
them to be your dog they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look yall Miss and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM got check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I
got's what you do stop that wase keep
keep that keep that going keep that
going go ahead look I guess you can say
that I'm
[Music]
very this call
proaim all cloud and clear a
proclamation of invitation turn not on
me c
the the River St lawence
[Music]
with I'mma just chilling watch them many
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then that will mistake me for adct
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and inv bite your girl to
your squadron cuz if you don't give with
that option you going to be single
player like Sovereign you going to get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to a Elemental what a avatar to a knee
Bender I got to be NE I know it's my
destiny work too who cares if you fly if
you still a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really be steo you like to
collect stuff and that's cool but I got
bad news even if you really was that
dude King that still be the king of the
statues since a juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hate it we meet in the boble other
than that it's cool and it's beautiful
we let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
is suitable cuz you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday a
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
[Music]
day yeah yeah yeah yeah Mike checks mik
checks give me a little soft give me a
little soft one two hello hello nice
faces cameras good stuff I like this I
like this let's get right into it here
you hear you and we are live and welcome
to the iron Lords podcast LLC and also
live on Lords of gaming.net episode
number
338 it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day and today we've got huge Microsoft
layos huge huge Microsoft
layos n Happ it they they have Tekken a
Impressions infinite wealth Impressions
and Nintendo investigating power world
to discuss so we're g to get right into
it so let's introduce the uhoh one's
missing one is missing what is going on
with our brother he ain't want to show
up he knew he knew what was going yeah
he was
hiding he's like man I can't I can't hit
this one can't do it yeah he's Tucker
one too many times the way to spin this
one yeah
know shut up they said your kid got laid
off too your astar is a
fo he said he got L he was one of the
said out said out the I love our
thoughts to King David this during this
difficult time you know uh you know he
may he may or may not have been affected
now all jokes inside that was good with
astop par that was that was fire that
was quick that was quick n n Shout out
to the homie he's going through
something little internet issue in the
area he hit us up let us know what's
going working on they're working on it
so he may still be able to join but
outage in the area you know what I'm
saying it's windy out there today
like I did Reach Out M and and I got a a
short a a quick you know replacement
it's the it's the person of the
community that I feel is the only person
that has the same energy as king and I'm
curious if if the chat knows who that
individual is so no doubt no doubt we G
see Spencer you guys feel Spencer the
C free King DAV out pocket Robin Kelly
King the line they Wilding right now no
doubt anyway but we still got three
other horsemen in the realm those
original Knights of the realm in the
round table my co-host the Coos my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of the
spin clap and the how and the young wolf
my man Lord adct back to back how we
doing sir doing pretty good uh yes the
spin clap stuff well you know originally
I wasn't going to have my cam until I
got my whole proud of you bro I'm really
proud of you bro there's too many people
in my comment section want to see me
slap and clap
you know what you know what no they want
to see me slap my thighs like I blame
Alex I blame Alex
started and they see me as a fellow
white dude I guess I guess all white
D you doing this for the Caucasian
Community well actually you know Alex is
more Cuban than anything but it's funny
man it's funny so yeah I will be
returning to face everything no doubt uh
tomorrow I will I apologize I only had
two videos was out last week uh I was in
New York scary New York for a couple
days
so shaking in my boots the whole time I
was there you was good man yo he was in
bougie Manhattan in Jersey City let me
tell you how ridiculous this man I'm out
here trying to impress this man take him
to nice places he like yeah that's that
was all right that that was was all
right he's like that's that wasn't all
that I think this New York food stuff
overrated so we
talking
I do think it is overrated I'm taking
this man everywhere right so get this
first thing I'm like so I'm like let me
leave it up to him what he want right so
I'm like yo what you want to eat right
now cuz it's lunch or whatever day it
was let's go to the chicken spot let's
go to the hood chicken spot he was yeah
this man loves the hood chicken SP to
the point where it's like yo we ain't
got nothing like that in
West like he was loving it yo the thing
here though is all right your guys'
pizza is the best pizza ever had but
like people acted like it was like this
giant like Gap and it's like this much
it's like this okay it's the best pizza
I've ever had but I I the pizza before
it it's not much better like like but
but that chicken W that chicken that
three piece chicken with fries there is
a there's a subst a substantial
difference between our chicken and that
chicken okay so we got the chicken title
when it comes to the the moms the Papas
the Hol wood fried the US Fried Chicken
K chicken you can ask you can ask Cog
too like he's like what do you want to
eat I like anything I can't eat at home
I I respect it like and then he took me
to this bougie like Chinese place it was
good food but my place is
better he just he wants mounds of food
that's what he want he was surprised
that I had chicken and waffles he was
like he has chicken and waffles oh yeah
you never seen Chicken and Waffles
together yeah King had to expl him like
that is a hood I mean that's a hood
thing but it's like a thing like Ros and
stuff like other spots yeah oh my God so
good that's what's up so what have we
been playing sir any games uh playing
infinite wealth nice you know my
uh I was sent the the PC version okay
sorry
smooth so you I've been playing that a
little bit I I'm really enjoying it the
beginning is like really really light MH
like I think the reason it's not really
bothering me as much is
because it it's cuz it's more of an
Easter egg towards like a dragon the
original yes so if you play that one you
can stand the first part a little bit
more but we'll get more into that when
we actually talk about infinite I do
have Tekken but I was sent the
PlayStation code and I literally cannot
find a PlayStation controller to save my
life I and I have like three of them and
I just don't know where they are and and
the funny thing is like I don't I don't
use the PlayStation so much like when I
do use it it's uh you know I move
everything at once and I think at one
point in time only was moving the
PlayStation so so that controller is
just wh watch that M controller
magically appear when rebirth comes out
oh yeah you know find it no really I
don't know where see what's funny is I
have a red one m I have a custom one and
I have two white ones well you have
three PlayStation controllers you can't
find one
I can't find one of them Jesus this like
I found the the the custom one but where
it's custom the joysticks popped out and
I can't find them okay so it's it's just
it's been it's been chaotic I feel you I
feel we going to get into that infinite
wealth a little later in detail the
third game I'm playing I can't talk
about cuz it's NDA NDA boys in the I
can't talk about it till the second oh
oh to the to the second bet okay okay I
I'm okay being
up all no doubt you already know and of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the
sras the Lord of crowns and Messiah of I
not that I like that and Lord praise the
I Bank PC Master races oh Lord Sovereign
how we do it you know you don't need to
editorialize that part there no there's
no need for foot context about we have
to inform the
audience what's going on BR chilling man
chilling uh it was a great week it was a
great week I'll let you talk about it
we'll just we'll just we'll just
uh expounded upon it but it was a great
week great week fantastic week not a
whole lot of gaming happened for me like
I wanted to get back to Prince of Persia
and lucky that I left it off like at at
at a safe spot you know one of those
those save trees they have so can kind
of look back and kind of see what I did
but otherwise I'd be lost so um I
haven't played any Prince of Persia this
week I did play you
play oh it's the rock Ally hold on let
me put that on let me pin that oh we got
that Techo the what what we running it
at I need some specs it's not it's oh it
is running at 60 running at 60 we were
we W the 60 medium I I have it at 900p
not 1080 not I ran 900 you don't really
need a 1080 on like
that and it's Dojo time like you know be
you never be you were never able to Dojo
on the go before with Tekken unless you
had like the PSP version or whatever but
um five PSP I remember that the last
time so I've been doing a little bit of
that uh King is I haven't played King
proper since 6 and I honestly I I have
not really really really played Tekken
since three like hardcore hardore yeah
that was that was your last run I I
really really fell off so um you know
making a concered effort to come back to
King and King is just a character that
requires study yes a lot a lot of study
so I'm having fun with that um I
installed it we can talk about it in a
te segment but I need this uh but yeah
we talk about in the tech segment I it
on the on the big computer but um and
that's pretty much it like I said said
it was a great week um and kago expound
upon that and King man I want to I
wanted King here man because I wanted us
all to talk about this I love but it was
cool and uh shout out to all of y'all I
never read the the the YouTube chats but
people were tight with me last oh last
week they was furious with you so many
bad takes I'm like where all the bad
takes I just because I don't agree with
Y it's a
bad I like how they spell it be like s
sa U
it's bad takes but not a one of you
spells the
name like solvent
Sol with a l yeah I did see that one I
see shout out to Y shout out shout out
to y'all for being
disagreeable disagree extending the show
out no doubt that's that's been it sir
that's pretty much been it yeah no doubt
no doubt and of course we have to G it
yourself the Shinobi Lord Cognito
spreading that realness in the r of the
IOP not telling you what you want what
you need to hear shout out to Mr mdpls
and defining Duke talking that Xbox
extended showcase and the Indies
initiative that they got going on on
Xbox um shout out to last word with
bontis no taiy Travis but we held it
down talk about the latest updates with
um destiny as well as the power world
phenomena Eagle super Hardo power world
he was telling me he was telling me what
he was doing so that was that but as far
as me man this this it's been a week for
you this this it's been a week right so
we going to get let me get to The Games
first then we get to the fun stuff but
um man we going to get into that tablet
but that teeken 8 has consumed my life
it is it's been insane as far as that
and then obviously um infinite wealth
we'll talk about haven't had as much
hours with that cuz I'm trying to get a
lot done with Tekken and then move on to
it and then um a little power when adct
pulled up to New York he showing me the
roast what I'm supposed to be doing how
to do the survival whatever but first of
all shout out to the New York game
Awards man shout out to the New York
game or 13th annual and um you know the
New York video games critic Circle you
know I I just love one what they
represent what they do that we're a part
of it and then also like I said giving
back to the to the communities as far as
in New York City students underserved
Community scholarships the man's office
was there obviously Neil drunkman
special moment you know giv the legend
award you know and uh for us it was just
big you know as a person who I was going
be from the city and and you know it was
one of those things where it's like it's
surreal to not only you know open up the
show right which was a big deal and in
front of your peers and open up for
Reggie you know Fe and May and stuff
like that but then the moment for me
where I was like I go for a proud dad
for me was when we the iron Lords came
up to present an award and all I think
we got the biggest pop bro we got pop
the pop was in the building the pop was
in the building shout out to hip hop
game shout out to one away dragon shout
out to a lot of people who pulled up
magic Jean shout out to um Tom medic
shout out to Tony palanco there was a
lot of people who know Mr Jo do like who
known us Albert oh shout out to Albert
yeah yeah shout out to shout out to
Justin on from Esports I think it's one
of the things that a lot of people who
have followed us from the very beginning
who remember you know the 100 subs or
you know 10 people in the chat or
whatever it was and to see them take
pictures of us in that moment and all of
us together presented we all kind of had
a little piece and and then brought out
the best arvr uh game award what was
humbling and then um for me personally I
won't take up the whole segment but for
me personally it was okay this is a
milestone moment we're living like a you
living your dream kind of thing and it
was surreal but I was just so proud like
I was just so proud of all of attic was
was cookie had this his fly little suit
on he came on stage did what he do you
know what I'm saying and then a
nightmare to buy that damn thing oh bro
we scramble we scramble to get off the
plane when you get you off the plane to
get that get the rest of the suit
situation popping we got it done but I
think yeah that and shout out to shout
out to Harold Goldberg you know shout
out to you know Ryan o' Calahan you know
executive director as well as the um
those guys are the founders Harold's the
founder of the New York video games
critic Circle I think also the
combination was getting a chance to
really ply with Neil M and see how down
the Earth he is it's how cool he is how
humble like some people you know how you
meet your Heroes and you know some of
them don't meet that expectation or the
energy maybe they just used to getting
swarmed and stuff and they don't want to
deal with people which is understandable
but nah man his son is genuine he was
just so so cool um again I got a lot to
say but I I'm give it to you I get let
let let me get adct first cuz I'm
curious like you know you came back came
back to the city you know what I'm
saying and why and then like what was
Jungle the jungle what was your feeling
on on the New York game awards and are
part of it as well as just your overall
experience I'm gonna be with with you
guys normally most of the time I don't
care about these type of uh you know
events or anything like that um but I do
feel like this is one of those
particular things where it's like if you
are especially if you're a coner Creator
you're on the East Coast like you got to
support this thing and the reason I say
that is cuz there's there's way too much
power in the industry on the west coast
there's way too much like like the the
balance is so much in on the west coast
that there's not even an adjacent one on
the east coast and you know it's it's
sad because it's just like until you
improve that that's the reason you don't
see a lot of people on the East Coast
get opportunities because they don't
live on the west coast and you know in
my experience a lot of you know the keep
people in the west coast they only
really operate with people on the west
coast so it's just like like I I don't
expect the west coast to build an East
Coast form formation it's up to us yeah
and until we build that until we have
that infrastructure that Community we're
going to continue to see the West Coast
running everything that's why what you
see so many streamers and so many
content C say I got to move to
California because that's the only like
if you truly want to take content
creation seriously you got to be where
all the opportunities are and until we
build them it's going to continue to
stay like that yeah we got got a support
and uh another thing I think we had
talked about this where we had um Dan
butchko on from play WIC so we talk
about like you know trying to get I
think one of the bigger problems is the
T tax breaks that are not afforded for
like games industry companies so it's
very difficult right for them you know
to kind of set up shop and do these kind
of things but for you s like what was
but why why would there be tax breaks
when like until we start building
infrastructure to make it appeasing for
companies get tax breaks they're going
to continue to give tax breaks to the
West Coast yeah it's very much if
there's not an infrastructure why would
they care I know I know it's more of a
New York thing but it was cool to see to
your point it was cool to see the
mayor's or represent for the mayor's
office there you know and seeing the
importance of video games and how it
changed the culture but no I get your
point I get your point and and we
definitely got to do better and we got
to continue to support what's going on
here in you know on the East Coast but s
your your thoughts on like the whole
event and just I was proud I was proud
you you had your little speech I was
like all right so where you at with it
man yeah first off shout out to adct for
helping me with my uh with my speech
because I left my reading glasses so I
was I was like struggling I'm like oh
man so adct was able to cut out what the
little blurb or whatever and and enlarge
it on my phone in a way where it was not
like bleeding off the edges of the phone
yeah so um cuz I was I you know you're a
little nervous and you're like oh damn
this is not working so um yeah I was
going to wing it but I was able to see
so it was good although although I I
would have liked to have looked up more
you know what I
mean not read as much but um but it was
again it's like how we like to say it
was like a movie right it was a movie
for us like we went there everybody's
all four of us are there loget is there
with Jean shout out to J we have our
friends from around the city yeah and I
was going to say I have to say like I
generally enjoyed maybe it's cuz I was
there and I wasn't at the uh you know
the the uh the other rewards video game
awards but I generally felt like that
award was set up better than the Video
Game
Awards to the point where uh you know
people were making fun of it oh you know
they're not going to rush you off
they're not going to rush you off Neil
had a couple B somebody else had to come
I did catch that cat that was funny it
would have been funny if we if we would
have had hooded Jeff key there this year
like he was last year oh yeah Jeff was
year before that's true Jeff was in the
building last year but not this year um
yeah um and that's what it is I think
the intimacy of the of the event je Park
was in the building in the chat right
now salute that's right je was in the
building had to give that man a big hug
Ben Smith
LSM I shared a a very manly man Smo with
benith benith said he wanted to smooch
me and of course I love that man oh you
better G like this talk mayor Nucky
Thompson of of the man came through for
sure no D yeah so um it was good to hang
out with those guys to see Jean gave
Jean a big hug man I've never met Jean
in person I was hoping to meet him at
colins's wedding and that didn't happen
um so yeah uh good to see good to see
everybody there and it was just it felt
like an event that was so full of love
New York love specifically right East
Coast love and it's nothing against the
West Coast but again like Alex said and
we had this conversation it was just
like let me address something I I make I
make jokes with the New York thing I'm
not scared of New York
I'm not talk about that no people are
really saying that you're terrified it's
a joke God you're too big to be scared
yeah he too
big good to you yeah in pictures y'all
really do notice how big king and addict
are y they be I'm always leaning over or
leaning back like you don't really see K
in the middle like y hey
guys I'm so tall that I get a range
depending on where I'm at in the picture
you got to be over here bro you got to
be in the air you can't be blocking
anybody off man father said n s we got
beef now west coast East Coast rivalry
is back rivalry let's go let's get
it but it was like yeah man it it was
great to to to see that love to hear
like you know the two loudest voices in
the auditorium always King yes and and
Hip Hop funny is they were they they
were cheering for completely different
things literally for the Xbox versus
PlayStation it was literally Xbox versus
PlayStation in the crowd between these
two with the nominees are getting
announced on scam and kick what you call
like DLC and then he's screaming out DLC
what you call like yeah Spider-Man this
that the Third King talking about now
Spider-Man going have no wins and like
they're having their own personal thing
going on while the show is going on it's
hilarious it's hilarious and these two D
you could like it's not a big Auditorium
so you can hear you can hear the
conversation yes um I mean it was just
it's a great time shout out to Harold
shout out to re shout out to Ryan
for having us there um you know Neil
like you said Neil it was funny cuz I
was I think I was the first one of us to
maybe you saw Neil before when they when
they pulled you away when I I was in the
GRE room in the green room right and we
were still over in the lobby but then
Neil came out right and he nobody had
noticed him yet and I was talking I
think it was me addict and King and
maybe somebody else was talking to us I
know Jean was there I think and I look
over to the side he's about to pull out
his phone because it's like nobody seen
him yet nobody swarmed him I'm like uhuh
put that phone away homie so I go over
there shake his hand congratulate him
tell him how much I love his games and
and quickly King came over I'm like but
this man has something to say to you
them two had a moment yeah they had a
moment cuz King go hard for Last of Us
he goes hard I know yall like oh no for
your Sak King goes hard for Last of Us
there was some people on Twitter like
you know I ain't I'm just going to say
hating um like we don't Have I None of
us on this show have ever ripped the
last of us have ever ripped Neil dman I
have maybe maybe may I definitely ripped
last of not necessarily ripped Last of
Us I just didn't like certain like story
aspects for Last of Us too you know I
will say that after meeting NE in person
I see him differently because I I I
didn't really all you could do is put
like a face like you can't really put a
personality and he's like one of the
most chilled back laid-back people I
I've ever met met in the industry like
you know you got people walking around
with like fullblown bodyguards and he's
like just walking around chilling he was
chilling so he it was like you know
listen we love the last of us there two
specifically King and I loved that game
and every everything everybody hates
about that game we love and to be able
to talk to him about it and just say you
know thank you for that um and and for
him to be as as sort of warm and sort of
receptive and just chilling there
talking to us taking pictures um it was
very very cool thing and you could tell
like when he went up to give a speech
and and I joked with him about it
afterwards it's like I was like you look
like you look like you would like wanted
to run off stage he's like I'm such an
introvert man like I don't I don't ever
really want to be doing that I just want
to be creating and not be the center of
anything um and it shows right and it
shows in his disposition his personality
he is that type of person um but it was
it was a beautiful night got to hang out
with the with the homies like you said
like Albert Dana we saw little some
jokes with Mr Joanna dark she was like
he's like hey sa I found this Starfield
uh jacket in the garbage along with the
copies of the
game
wow yeah so many people in the building
I think Bethesda was in the building
Bethesda was in the building yeah last
shot I want to give is I really love
that the New York game awards gives the
developers their flowers yes as far as
giving them the time to get all the sh
to speak to do like that means so much
to me and and the categories and stuff
like it it was just dope man and what
they did for me I highly recommend again
go to um nyv videoc critic.com go check
that out yeah it's it's it's really cool
if you want to see the um Whata call the
show itself you missed it it's still up
on YouTube I'm putting the link in the
description you want to see us come out
there guessup interrup I saw a lot of
people say stuff like oh you know are
they ever going to have like video game
announcements like watch the show and
when they get the viewership they can
justify the video game announcement
here's the thing like
I do believe that if you guys show up
and you watch these they will get the
announcements sooner or later support
it's hard to convince like a developer
or publisher to give them trailers when
you know the traffic's not necessarily
there so like give it a chance guys like
you know it's it's a fun little time
like you know and this is you know we
say we want people to take stuff more
seriously in the gaming industry you got
to show up when people actually try to
do it that's a fact yeah like anything
in this industry it only like you know
it's it's it's only going to grow and
evolve with with support and absolutely
need the support and we would so we
can't go we can't finish off without
mentioning the true purpose of why this
was all done and created was the fact is
it's basically
to educate and empower the youth
specifically of the Bronx or our
hometown right but it I'm I'm assuming
the goal is to reach all of New York
City of the Bronx
to understand that these things that
they're passionate about these games
this industry there's places for them
and they're that they're not sort of
they're not they're not incapable of of
sort of breaching that barrier and
getting into the game Space and becoming
either writers or devs in some way shape
or form a journalist something of that
matter um and you know thanks to like
Rockstar and other New York based you
know devs a lot of these kids are able
to have opportunities to be interns at
these places imagine interning at
Rockstar yo I'm jealous man wish
programs when we was coming up man
exactly and that's the thing for us
coming up in New York City in the Bronx
and not having any of this yeah it is
such a proud moment to see that this is
happening and for us to you know
hopefully become a a more integral part
of it as as time goes on is is a special
thing and you know shout out to Harold
for seeing that need and looking for a
way to address it shout out to to Ryan
for sort of now being sort of at the the
Forefront of that along with har being a
teacher he understands the needs he
understands what they need to do and
then shout out to Reggie as well and
everybody else on that on that board who
sort of gives up their time to and you
know Reggie Phil obviously Neil now give
of their time to to teach these kids
that hey there's a place for you here
don't think that if you're not a math
person you can't get into the games
industry don't think that if you're
you're like we were talking about you're
not on the west coast you can't get into
the games industry um it it empowers
these kids to follow their dreams cuz
when you're a kid chances are you
probably like like video games right you
know the the idea of I'm going to be a
doctor I'm going to be an astronaut
maybe it's a little more abstract but
video games you probably play every
single day and say hey I love this what
if I could do this and there's so many
Avenues to get in but they just don't
know and you know coming from where we
come from it's still not easy like I
would say it's not I would say it's
harder now than it was when we were
coming up in a lot of ways way yeah cuz
it's more competition now than there was
it's more competition and just just like
you know there's been in some ways right
I kind of feel like the border of vet
has deteriorated somewhat I mean there's
there's no school that it was like the
school that kog and I attended anymore
like it isn't that anymore so and
there's so much overcrowding and
multiple schools in one building and
it's a lot so to see these kids getting
the specialized attention to sort of be
able to sort of fulfill the things that
they're passionate about and their
dreams it's it's a special thing so I'm
glad that we're part of it absolutely
and shout out to King David for having
the greatest job of the evening man was
the number one shooter for Reggie Fe and
maywe he's he was instructed to protect
Reggie for the night and it wasn't
nobody getting next to Reggie unless
Reggie told King it was a go so shout
out to the number one shooter on Deck
King David new job assignment this was
holding the whole building down we were
the Lords were entrusted to hold down
Reggie but but King took the jobs very
serious was thing is you know King has
done this in the past years ago right so
the thing I noticed and I was like
standing and watching because Reggie
kind of takes one corner of the bar and
people come to talk to him whatever but
if there's no one around him he will get
swarmed by people overwhelming over last
year last year he was he was swarmed and
it was there was you know whoever he had
with whatever didn't stay or whatever
the case may be he was more swarmed last
year so he wanted just to be able to
kind of single file talk to people or
whatever yeah and I'm looking at King
and it's just like King is having
conversations with people while out of
his periphery noticing who's trying to
you know pull up on regie and it's just
literally just a slight movement of the
body without even looking at the IND n
you're not going nowhere n you're not
doing that you're going nowhere oh and
then he slides back to another position
talking to somebody da da da da da never
looks up look talking to whoever he's
talking to next person he sees out of
his periphery try to sneak behind hey
what's going on what's going on what's
up what's up what's popping like King
and person is is a different Beast you
got a ticket you got a ticket yes he
look at regie he good you good all right
cool yo King was holding the spot down
bro it was for us I just looking I'm
like look where we all come from yeah
and we could tell a story that we're in
the room with Neil dman Reggie Fe all
these luminaries and we're holding them
down like bro you this is dream stuff so
I like it's Bronx boys taking care of a
bron bron boys salute you already know
but yeah New York g go check that out
I'll put the link in what's
up man hip hop what's going
on up let me tell you something brother
like you like people could say what they
want like I've been podcast for a while
obviously you OG in the game you
inspired a lot of us to get into the
game cuz we watch you you know I've been
I've been there since shot fight you
know saying all you know what I'm saying
so my thing is it's one thing to cuz you
do this more more than me like you up in
front of crowds you you do this so like
it's one thing to be behind my computer
and be like introducing it's another
thing to get on the stage and be like
introduc and Reggie and like and here's
the thing when you setting it off in the
building like you the first to set it
off you know saying it's a little
pressure with that but I go the tone
facts so when I get up one second I just
got to give hip hop is his flowers on so
I get up there so I'm like Co just be
yourself have fun don't get too crazy
with it and I look and I see you I
focusing on you so then you like yeah I
LS in the building what's going on I'm
like oh I'm good I'm good I said hi hop
gave me strength right now I'm good
right now I love you bro but continue
adding and I just want I had to tell hip
hop that what was going on
while I'm doing it salute yeah I I was
going to say I'll never forget like one
of the most nerve-wracking things that's
ever happened to me and I've said the
story before but you know we've grown a
lot since then I was it was at like the
second pack East Bo went to and I was
walking down and Hip Hop was like
essentially shoutcasting for
AMD so he's sitting there and he's got
this this microphone he's like and I'm
walking by he's like oh my God the
Lord's here at Florida keep in mind
there's probably 100 people between me
and him like this man did not just do
facts hip hop what was your experience
man New York game was you was in the
building tell me about your experience
brother yo son I was just hyped to see
everything son you know what I'm saying
like you know how I get down son seeing
y'all go up there seeing my man Tony
palanco hit the
St saying shev Smith killing it you know
mean my man har Ryan just everybody I
was just happy to be you know what I'm
saying big V BX it going down so for me
um it was just great to be in a room
with love you know what I'm saying like
the Energy felt real different like like
for example when you go to like the game
awards you know what I'm saying out in
La um that's dope too but it wasn't this
so here the difference right the
difference is I was at a concert with my
man krs1 right oh you ain't GNA just
slide that you was chilling with the
teacher you you a building okay yeah so
I was with uh ks1 right and um he had uh
did a show at sobs now he said he could
have did the same show at Yankee Stadium
himself and sold out 30,000 whatever but
you can you can never forget where you
come from and that love and that core
and that Royal energy and also reaching
the people that may not have an
opportunity to go to the G stadiums of
the world so to me the New York game
awards is the foundation in the culture
it's the concrete of why we love games
and why we love the C
you know I'm say everything got to be
like commercial and status and my click
and your click sometimes it's just we
here for a bigger person purpose bigger
than us and that's what the NY game
awards was and that's why like being in
that room and seeing y'all go up that
energy was just on a thousand plus
another thousand and I love y'all for it
so that's the way was for me when I was
in there as soon as I walked in son I
seen K
SE I came out to um Escalade you know
say
like that in like yo what up you know
mean soon as I walk in you know how it
is was sh Bel was Shing was amazing and
and also come on man Neil dman was in
the CH yo shout out to Neil dman CA he's
a big fan of meth the man and red man
say word I was talking hip hop I missed
that part we was talking hip hop yeah
son because like yo all so fun fact you
know people see me with K Capri ks1 you
about to see another icon that I got
with me likeo it's different over here
they call meop G for a reason so get
ready but I'm telling you Neil dman is a
hip-hop head and I I asked him
personally I was like yo like if there's
a hip-hop artist that you could bring
into your next game or just work with or
something like that who would it be and
he was like I work with logic before and
something like
that yeah but he was like I would love
to get metha man or red man on something
so I said all right say no more oh okay
y'all cooking okay I think y I think I
caught the tail end of this cuz y'all
was talking towards the end of the oh
that's what's up Salute I'm mad I get a
part of that
conversation yeah ask King about it
that's I speaking of King last I know
your time was little but last day y'all
two are the funniest yo every award this
King like yeah PlayStation in the
building yeah yeah we won that if they
start you know it was on when the
multiple choice before the show started
and they go PlayStation vers
Xbox it was pretty like I was sitting
there cuz you had I saw I was like isn't
that a way to start a
console yo if Y what it is is they both
so loud and the way the theater the the
the the the audio travels it was just
funny because you can hear it you know
what I'm saying but they it was it was
all love man love you bro like that was
a moment we was die laughing with y'all
man salute salute it was crazy man it
was so like I appreciate y'all man and
when I tell y'all like ILP is like so
huge I'm tell y something right now like
because I was already talking I said
this years ago and I said that um XBox
should have um Iron lws podcast on the
dashboard of their system so the moment
you turn on your Xbox you see Iron LS
podcast you see gamertag radio like you
see all these things like culturally so
um I like this keep going speak it to
existence yeah so let's just say I'm
blessed to be in such a like you know
incredible powerful position not just in
gaming culture but in culture period
entertainment fashion you name it so um
like let's just say I was with somebody
like yesterday okay
okay that um is like a alumni you know
what I'm saying Microsoft family and uh
we we got to make this happen man you
know we ain't just talking about
it y'all really need to be you know like
Jason Ronald that's my
dude like yo we need
ILP needs to be on that dashboard when
you turn on an Xbox system I'm with it
we gonna make it happen we gonna make it
we we G have to come to the office CU we
G I'm going have to eat all my words
then I love y'all I love y listen
brother no I mean it too I mean yo the
sky's the limit the potential is there
there's a lot of things and dreams that
we want to accomplish you know that
night was was very special and one of
those but I agree with you hipop we got
to take this thing further and obviously
you're an inspiration and we go into the
office cuz this got to go down and meet
with your man and really build like
really build and that's what I love
about you everybody bring coming
together and ring each other up instead
of all this you know what I'm saying we
could be stronger together so salute to
you brother defitely hiop is one of the
few people I know that has connections
that doesn't hesitate to share those
connections no no we we good we all
build it other people I talk to they
just be like nah I'm good like we ain't
we cuz cuz hip hop is confident in
himself other people see you as as
potential competition if you get too big
Hip Hop's like we all can Thrive
together we don't have to to to start
gatekeeping who gets emails and and who
gets this and who gets that like that's
what's actually going to grow the
community it's one of the I will say
it's one of the reasons that the West
Coast does so well is because they are
very clickish with each other and
they're very helpful to help each other
you know besides hip hop there's not a
lot of people on the East Coast I know
like that like yeah we got to do better
we got to do better yeah like no fact uh
adct is absolutely right remember um
I'll just bring this up real quick uh
all the way back in the day in the n4g
days know and stuff like that right
I'm going just keep it a buck with you
the first year I ever went to E3 shout
out to my brother Torrence Davis who
gave me
my yes so like Torres told me personally
he's like yo you're not gonna need me
like after this because of the way I you
know performed and like got things done
in ' 08 right so at ' 09 I had like nine
people come with me to E3 that's how big
everything got and you know trying to
help people spread the love put people
on you know you trying to do all these
things and what's crazy is I was met
with a lot of people saying like hip hop
Gamers shouldn't
represent like the gaming culture
because the way he talks or the way he
looks that's not professional that's not
considered this that's not considered
that and then like then there was times
where things would happen to me and I
would try to like fight the situation
where it's like no this is wrong like
like
U may have taken an article from me and
then it'll get taken down but to stay up
and I'm like info what's up what's up
with that here's the receipts what's up
why happening but what I learned is it's
not even about being right or wrong or
about being real you know a lot of times
in the space so once I learned that and
I understood how to navigate things I
was like oh okay I see how this go
there's really no difference from the
hood and the way I started navigating
the business side of the gaming industry
so what it realize it's like another
language
like to navigate in the industry yeah
it's different so what happened is I'm
the kind of person where um because of
where I come from and you know I grew up
I'm very comfortable in pressure
situations I'm very comfortable with
things going against me so when you
think it's hurting me you're actually
helping me because I'm actually built
for it whereas I'm built for something
that you're not so now we going to see
and this is why I tell a lot of people
and even right now I tell a lot of
content creators you know be careful
like how you place value on yourself the
more you label yourself as a like a
subscriber a follow a follower a number
the moment you label yourself like that
where it's like hey I got these
followers or I got this number so then
you're only going to be as good as that
and then if your numbers start to go
down or things that's out of your
control start happening yeah you got to
keep up this facade now and then you'll
do anything to keep that and then that
creates Reckless Behavior and then next
you know Twitter fingers is all over
place trying to tell people is always
operate at the source like everybody
that's listening right now always
operate at the source because people can
say whatever they want but when you
operate at the source that's when you
are actually in control and your
relationships are a lot stronger so for
me I never had a job in the gaming
industry at all I always been
independent since day one y see how I
move connections I help people I say
this I say that but at the end of the
day I just mind my business do my thing
and then you read about it later so at
the end of the day whoever needs help
I'm always open I'm always down but
remember nobody owes you anything first
with everything that you do and if you
truly truly love the gaming industry and
you love what you do and you love the
culture everything else will fall into
place properly as long as you love it so
keep loving it well said brother
he preaching off so get some balls hiop
we got keep a little I to give hip hop
some balls though n i me yeah you you
know we spoke a little bit and like like
you were saying like it's time to build
it's time to really grow this and sit
down and chop this up and and grow this
thing because again like we were talking
about with the east coast is like for us
this this like sort of intimate setting
for the game awards the fact that that
is built off of trying to teach the kids
and that come from where we come from
that there's a better way there's a
better way and these things that that
that we grow up loving that our parents
are like oh yeah it's not going to
amount to anything you're wasting your
time whatever now it's this multi-
billion dollar trillion dollar everybody
want a partner now everybody know about
video games now right with so many
Avenues to be successful in and the fact
that we get to be a part of that and
it's all it's all thanks to you and the
positivity bro because the thing is if
you don't have somebody like you that's
that that's spitting what you spit and
talking the way you talk about how you
want to move in the industry whether
it's for a personal reason or just how
you want to project who you are where
you're from and how much you love the
games I if if not for that everybody
starts falling into like you said
Twitter fingers and every everything
becomes negativity everything becomes
all this stuff that isn't even real it
just kind of lives in The Ether on
Twitter it's not even real fact this
these things that we're doing they're
real and they're going to make a real
impact and that's to me the biggest
thing that we get to do this together
you you're helping us out in terms of
what we're able to do who we're able to
access and and and kind of increasing
our reach at the same time creating this
this hopefully powerful Network moving
forward that that allows this space to
grow in ways you know that that we're
going to see more people with faces like
ours yes absolutely absolutely that's an
important thing man so I always love
brother always always love abute you man
last thing I say before I step out of
here son is uh the program because you
talking about the kids and everything so
the program that I got is called
Playmakers and I'm a partner with the
Board of Education also I'm a I'm a
minority business Enterprise certified
company as well you know what I'm saying
um I'm also partnered with Chase Bank
New York Stock Exchange naturally
syndicated like all of these other
things so here's what I want to tell
y'all I actually got kids going to
school right now getting paid to play
games right now we just did first
session on the Ninja on the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles shreders Revenge
game yeah we had the kids six seventh or
eightth graders play the games and when
you hear the way they speak on games I
will put money up against my like the
kids that I rock with yeah against any
journalist okay on I don't care if it's
IGN game spot like what you name it I
will take the kids that I rock rock with
against anybody and you will be
surprised at the difference the passion
the detail that you would get from them
versus the criticism and the
the the anal thought process yeah that
you see in today's culture when it comes
to gaming
because a lot of the kids when they play
the game they play free yeah they play
for having fun enjoy in enjoyment
whereas when you have a job and you and
you got you thinking of clicks and you
don't want to get fired you're playing
mindset different you're playing from a
standpoint of
fear no it's the mindset different okay
yeah so when you playing free you can be
honest be real and enjoyful when you
playing for fear regardless of what the
truth is I got to keep this job because
I got a family to feed I I don't knock
nobody's Hustle facts what I am saying
is there's a lot that come with the T
territory with the with the way you
decide to operate within your field no
that's fact so so I'mma say it like this
the kids got all the kids got a $100 dog
to play the game review the game tell me
what they thought it was all on OBS they
got filmed I got
everything crazy dope and it's a gaming
team and it's just like how you got a
basketball team or NFL team in school
you got a gaming team in school it's
crazy
unb orts it's gaming as a and when I
tell y'all to see so many kids there's
this one girl this one black girl and
she was so intricate dog on the way she
broke down Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and all the kids was talking about how
much they loved the 90s uh hip
hop Ninja Turtles game all of them said
that like and this is on their own and
what's so crazy about that is these 10
11 year olds they weren't even Bor you
would think that they would love the hip
hop from back in the day and they love
it because they experienc it through
video games yo do yo bro this is what we
do what we doing yo real quick where can
I know you got it cooking but like where
can people find information or just stay
tuned or when it's about to go there cuz
you spitting right now and we need to
have the people support this so should
they follow the Twitter account and stay
tuned to that what where should they be
tuned in for the next move
follow me dog Instagram Twitter Google
me whatever everything is hip hop gamer
just follow me and my email is right
there hip hop gamer hiip Hop gamer. net
or you can connect with me on IG
whatever like I'm a like approachable
person like you know what I'm saying you
can hit me up like it's fine I'll get
back to you or my team will get back to
you but either way we'll make it happen
in the chat right now support my man he
got things cooking right now for the
culture you already know hiop I
appreciate you brother you already know
always love the legendary hiph hop gamer
you already know brother love you
bro all right no doubt salute salute
adct um I mean s we got any Super chats
yeah we got a few we got a few got a few
all right let's put the Crush in the
chat for Lord Silva Hector the Macho Man
oh
yeah then we got dror
strange uhoh with a with a normal super
chat $5 Super Chat normal y'all need to
give Microsoft the smoke today there's
no excuse for a trillion dollar company
to fire 1,00 people these companies are
not our friends yes that is true they're
not our friends we will
discuss and we got Forza Legend member
for 49 months Lord bronze people act
like Phil didn't say there would be
massive changes once the merger was done
I believe people hear what they want to
hear honestly we'll discuss we will
discuss
there we got gabing Forte remember for
49 months Lord bronze at 6:30 eastern
time the weight of the pride will bear
down on the ners HG I'll be checking for
proof of Life regularly during the game
score 32 to 27 liines he talking he
talking I'm staying quiet I'm staying
quiet I got my redit gold on but I'm
staying quiet we going to see what
happened but salute to Forte salute to
the lines you already know I got love
for them you know what I'm saying me me
and Forte talked before we both got
respect for each other so if we pulling
for the other one whoever win we pulling
for them as a representative for the
super you always you always got to you
if if you get beat I think it's just
good etiquette to to support the team
that beat you except except the teams
you can absolutely stand and I don't I
don't have no beef with the lions like
i' I've been rocking I've loved them
since the Barry sers days no beef I feel
the same way I don't watch football like
that anymore I will watch championship
games yeah uh Barry Sanders made me a
lions fan and I was I was well I was a
Barry Sanders fan right along with him
came the Lions and that dude was so
special that I was just like I would
take Barry Sanders in every game
Techo and really only only Bo Jackson
was kind of outdoing Barry Sanders was
just oh Jesus Christ already know so
what else we got okay so in response to
Forte soowo backs slap remember for 43
months Lord Bron's gaming fraud is not a
real allons fan he is a fair wether
fan Real Lies fan he'd already know
their fate based on history oh no not
the
Expos so he call sow more calling it it
ain't happening not today Satan not
today then we got Robert Kell $5 Super
Chat blessed day thoughts on Xbox
getting the bad Port of power world I
know it's early access but how it runs
only push me to play OG
Pokemon wow oh wow salute hopefully like
I said what is it uh pocket pair said
they got some updates coming soon so we
see yeah I mean it was they already knew
it was a couple of updates behind so
yeah yeah yeah part of the issue I do
have with that is like we do know that
Microsoft gave them a pretty substantial
bag to go Game Pass so it's just like
man like I I would have pushed for the
whole thing to be delayed before I get
the G version of it that is true that is
true at least have the server part
portion of it yeah hopefully they get
that resolved to
rectify then we got Tyrone
ligums Super Chat yeah I I heard Queenie
been having problems with his ships and
starfields I let him ride my rocket to
the moon charge boo boo wow whoa who
who's doing
whoy I guess King he talk about n he
ain't talk about the
car he ain't talk about that can't come
for
the man out here to defend no let not do
that please elaborate on who you're
talking maybe maybe don't maybe don't
maybe don't yeah let's not let's let's
keep it moving there we got Robert Kell
again $5 Super Chat hyped to see the
Lords this March can't wait for me and
Astro to tell everyone why Sonic is Peak
fiction that is correct as a reminder we
will be at PX East in March and then
coming in hot on March 24th we will be
opening the show for sacred symbols 300
NYC at the very same theater where the
game awards were held the SBA theater
SBA up going to be hot pull up I heard
them tickets went like fire yes and I
heard the tickets and King I'm telling
you right now he got things cooking for
this he got plans for that show I just
all I'm saying is whatever's left of the
because I know they sold all the
VIPs when those go
public if you guys live in that New York
area facts I would be there
saying I might have to I might have to
point out I don't know that
dude K is definitely looking to set it
off let's just say
that no doubt to put it this way he was
joking with the people from LSM saying
what he was going to do and they said
now King I expect you to do it so it
gave him the green light the green
light was like I would be mad if you
didn't do this woo listen y'all better
be ready yall know yall know how to how
the front line do yeah the pull up is
going to be
hilarious fun yeah we'll most likely be
at the VIP session yeah yeah yeah we'll
see we'll see um let me
see oh gaming Forte $5 Super Chat never
said I was a patriot never said I was
Patriots until I die slowmo always been
a lions fan but your boy ain't those
like those Cowboys fans that believe for
the for belief's
sake he rocking with two T's cheating he
rocking well he doesn't really have
faith in one of them he doesn't really
have faith in one of them they they yeah
now they up he
back I got you Forte betrayed you once
too many times that a lot of pain you
had to let that go no no what else you
got there we got harit chani member for
31 months Lord gold shout out to I for
presenting at the New York game awards
adding to the totals Nintendo and Xbox
get another game award each and of
course PlayStation Spider-Man comes away
empty-handed with no award yes I believe
the I believe the number nine was
getting
uh pass around Messi nine losses yeah
Messi Salu hugi sh then we have bti $2
super W Lords enough
respect enough respect respect B you're
you're done now
done I like adct Jama I like Jamaican
adct
I like Jamaican again let me get one
more baby snow baby snow baby
snow we got to get inform and play for
let hear the lyrics to
inform no doubt we have Marvin gar $2
Super Chat my my zou got hands for
anybody that want them Cog oh all right
yeah so this what we going to do here's
the thing when you see us on we probably
setting up player matches we probably
put about 6 to eight in the room we're
going to start bringing people in the
community yeah cuz it it's fun tet is
too fun so yeah I'm I'm down for all the
smoke and I need to know what Y young
kids do it cuz y'all beat y Savages in
this game I got to catch you know I got
got my my reflexes bro I got to get a
dojo but I mean I'm solid right now but
I ain't where I need to be but yeah yeah
we we'll get that going bro I had told
you my friend Ronnie used to always
think he was a like
a had to had God until he got online
yeah yeah online I humble you quick yeah
online in the arcades for us back in the
day it'll it'll let you know facts bro
what let you know we still pretty good
but we're still pretty good but um
what'll let you know now is Tekken A
ranked keep play I was in their rank I
was oh the these boys getting it in what
saying we going to talk about te we
going to talk about Teek a little uh let
me see Doctor Strange Love once again $5
Super Chat sa next time Security will
not stop me from seeing you my Savi Wabi
no no there is no barrier of force on
this planet that will keep me from you
yeah somebody like that Ben we had we
had we had the shooters on Deck had to
Shooters on Deck yeah they definitely
would have tackled
you had Neil ready to jump Neil was
right there
ready did you guys just not hear us say
that that King was the personal security
guard Reggie like you guys really want
to play that game yeah I want to play
that game not here not in our home
tur what else we got then we have Daddy
passion official $2 Super Chat Tekken 8
is all kinds of fire yes yes yes it is
all kind of that Unreal Engine five is
oh my Lord good
God then we got Doctor Strange Love
Again $2 Super Chat that nasty blue rat
has never had a good game disrespect
Sonic disrespect my man Kelly get
him and it would not be a Sunday without
JD gamer $ super chat but part begging
ponies ain't got no games here we go you
need to you need to TM that statement
yes PPP
loans hey we caught up all right cool
cool cool no doubt now it's my turn to
get to talking we got um Pat questions
you got about three actually one more
Super Chat roll there okay hold on a
second let me go back down JD gamer once
again $10 Super Chat Microsoft Lang off
people as any profit-minded business
would when you have three people doing
the same jobs two of which you don't
don't need who and what company and what
company employs people that that they
don't need just for looks that's true we
will talk we will discuss we will we
will talk and Doctor Strange Love once
again $ Super Chat MK1 in the trash
check a clearing it say I yeah we'll
talk we'll talk we gonna talk sh love
about that one for sure for sure what
else we got we good that's it we caugh
up no doubt no doubt these patrion I see
my man D gy in the building get a mic
check right quick D before I do my
patreon questions make sure you
good uh too low too high yeah we got to
bring you up we got to get the levels up
got to get the levels up we got maybe go
up in the zoom settings or get your mic
setting we gotta hear hear the dirt you
right know I'm good yeah yeah you good
now now you good I'm good now no doubt
salute appreciate you let me get these
patreon questions in the realm uh Doo
padra hello Lords first congratulations
to all of you for hosting such an
important event at New York hope you are
all in good spirits and health I know
you will talk to layoffs around
Microsoft in the industry itself so I
leave that to y'all but I need to talk
about the WB review code situation I
don't like these news outlets only Cry
Wolf about not getting review codes when
it affects them nobody and I mean nobody
is entitled to a review code going to
Twitter to voice is shout why the review
is not out and putting blame on WB
because they didn't give someone a code
is ridiculous how many times have
reviews been in progress at this at the
time the game came out when codes were
given this ain't new Gamers KN knew this
know this but now it affects them when
then they use the excuse oh but people
were asking about it people ask about
anything on social media I'm sorry about
my rant have a blessed Sunday Lord so
this looks like a hot one the WB
situation ad will set this
off you muted oh I don't hear yeah he
mut there was no lies detected in that
you your arms saying there was no there
was no lies behind that statement I
can't you guys know how I feel about you
know sometimes I feel like the media
some of the most entitled people you
know when when when I go the same people
that tell
me when I say I I I feel a way when a
company worked with us over and over
again when it benefits them but when it
would benefit us with like a bigger game
you know they don't respond when I go on
rants these are the same people that say
add you're not entitled but these are
the same people on Twitter saying why
didn't we get a code it's like at the
end of the day it's like look like no
one's entitled to a code now I do think
you know the way things are handled with
code reviews is weird like some people
would get codes like long before other
people and to me if you were going to
get get a code you shouldn't have like
to me like for instance infinite wealth
was like really weird on how things went
like on that so it's just like
if you're going to get a code on day one
of the review process but they send it
to you maybe a week before the game
comes out uh and then some people got it
three weeks before the game comes out
that's where I'm like that doesn't make
a whole lot of sense if you were going
to get a code I wish the industry would
just start handling that more
effectively and just give everyone the
code at the same time because to
me first off you give certain sites
codes I remember Dying Light too didn't
give they were very bougie about certain
media Outlets getting codes before other
ones and it's like all you really do is
take advantage of people that want this
bad and what are they going to do when
they get a code two or three days before
the game comes out and they have no
choice they're going to know life that
do unhealthy stuff when when in some
cases people that get a fraction of of
your viewership on a media site because
you're on YouTube and you're getting a
lot more consistently and you have a
more dedicated fan base they're getting
codes weeks before you get codes so it's
just like to me if you were going to get
a code this is only if you're going to
get a code now if you didn't get a code
that's one thing that's different but if
you end up getting a code for that game
like a day before it came out and
there's people that's had it for weeks I
don't like that because like separation
okay yeah there there shouldn't be no
separation like to me all you're doing
there is especially smaller influencers
because they want it bad that they're
going to stay up for for a day or two
trying to finish it just so they can get
coverage and you don't necessarily have
to do that but especially when you're
when you're right out the gate in these
YouTube streets you think you need to do
that and it's to me if you're going to
give these people codes let them
effectively cover your game yeah enough
time because at that point it makes it
seem like you're think you're just doing
charity work and these people should be
lucky that they're getting the code in
general so it's like you don't give them
time to actually cover your
game and sometimes I I feel like
Publishers and developers you know they
do that on purpose because they're they
know that maybe they don't want as many
people talking about their game at
launch like lot a lot of politics a lot
of things there's certain things how
codes are handled you know I've already
appreciated about you know anyone that
works with us give us codes uh but there
are certain people and we don't really
work with too many of them that it's
just like I just scratch my head how
they handle codes and I get it leg
istically it makes sense to some degree
but at the same time it's like if you're
going to give people codes just give
them codes don't make them wait a day
before the game comes out because at
that point like what's the point I don't
have no problem buying your game I want
to cover your game it's one of the
reasons I went to streaming no I because
it makes it do it makes it a lot easier
to cover games if you stream than it
does if you're just like make a review
and you get a game a day before that's a
debt like unless you sit there and play
that game for two or three days straight
don't get sleep do a review that's over
yeah cuz then you miss the zeit guys
most likely once they and people say and
then the media click baites everything
and you know it is what it is you know I
I personally think that you know it's
not just Dustin because Dustin's the
person clearly we're talking about uh
it's it's a variety of everyone you know
I think everyone needs to come together
and say you know we think we need uh you
know particularly how things done and at
the same time it's like you know I did
see some of the previews
and it did seem like here's the thing
like I don't mind if people compare
games to other games cuz that's what
they're used to but if you start
penalizing a game for what a studio is
trying to do new they're not making a
Batman Arkham Asylum game they're making
something different so to me you can
penalize on the combat me personally I
don't like it because of the combat but
you don't see me like y you know I'm not
Batman like it's just like to me that's
where on the merits of what what the
game to okay I where you go no I got you
solve your thoughts on the whole uh
situation with WB and and certain
outlets and whatever people saying they
not get into codes a little bit of a you
know hubub on social media um so I don't
know how true this is but but apparently
not everybody's getting C like hear a
lot of people many if any yeah the games
don't go live until the servers go live
but
you early access they bought Early
Access getting that right so the Early
Access apparently goes live Monday right
so apparently tomorrow Igan i' even
getting that I guess yeah yeah so look I
looking at the at the article that Tom
Marx printed saying you know what you
know he doesn't say anything egregious
that makes it sound like they sound
entitled they're saying look we're not
going to have it when you're the biggest
we Gaming website on the planet people
are going to wonder why you don't have
something so he got out in front of it
and said we don't have it and he said
look they told us that we're not going
to get codes at all so we're going to
buy our codes and we're going to have
the coverage to you when we can we can
have it and look at our preview coverage
if you want to have an idea of what our
you know our preview or start about the
game so it it was a lot of a lot tell me
how that Ain some ballsy moves right now
you already know what we vote in this
game look at our preview coverage we
like like but see but that's that's you
inferring that that's what they mean by
that like if they had come out and said
something I see this I just feel like it
was an opportunity for everybody on the
internet to just jump on them and be
like yeah I did I mean let's let's be
real here W's for you let's be real here
this is probably Warner Brother trying
to Dam like premature damage control of
the game because I don't see a lot of
people I don't see the game reviewing
well I might be wrong you know I played
the story the story found like it is a
solid experience with talk you're
allowed to talk about that sir just
makeing sure no no they they they they
broke the embar
okay they got so much bad publicity
they're like yo the old people they had
better put that out there put that out
yeah so it's it's you know I did I like
the story I just didn't like the game
play that was my big thing uh so you
know I think people might generate
because King loved it yeah yeah you know
kai loved it so people might end up
generating like liking this game but
like to the masses I don't think it's
going to do well I might be wrong I hope
I'm wrong uh but I I think this might be
Warner brother just trying to like you
know be be a little selective but that's
that's their job too PR is to do what
they can to make the game s better
protect the product right I don't agree
with it that's why I said I feel like
the industry needs to change in certain
ways but you know who am I to tell you
know a company that's trying to save
sales not to save sales I can disagree
with the process but I understand why
they're doing it yeah hey I have a
question I'm sorry for this I have a
question um so I really haven't been
following this story yeah too much so so
I'm I'm assuming that IGN didn't get the
review codes and they're upset about it
and they went on Twitter and vocally
talked about why they didn't get the
codes or that they don't have the codes
right that's what we're talking about
yeah that's pretty much the gist of it
so I have a question do you guys think
um I do remember IGN dropping some
previews and saying the pretty much
saying the game was trash you know I'm
I'm paraphrasing here but they said the
game wasn't that great do you think WB
is kind of like oh
oh yeah we saw y previews y p did the
preview it could 100% be the case right
because we talked about it that it was
like that title is unnecessarily sort of
drawing attention to the fact that if
somebody just wants to read about how
much someone dislikes this they're going
to jump on it and it's it's going to
feel like it's inflammatory right as
opposed to just saying this is our
preview coverage of this game read it no
they already told you what they thought
about it in the title which yeah they
did right and which is you know you
didn't have to do that right and it and
it goes it speaks to two different
things right this idea that now even the
biggest platform on gaming platform on
the planet now has to uh you know scrape
SEO for like titles that's going to give
you clicks um and at the same time it is
this thing where it's like as opposed to
letting the the public it and find out
about it through what you said a lot of
people are looking at the title saying
okay it sucks they think it sucks I
don't need to read this I don't need to
play this and influencing in that way so
I I could see that happening but if that
were the case I would I would see that
more people are saying they have the
game right as a and it feeling more like
they were punishing quote unquote IGN
for this um I haven't really seen that
so it could be more to what's addict
saying which is like Hey we're going to
protect this game to the very last
second that we can um we know it's going
to be divisive we know some people like
it a lot we know some people don't like
it a lot right that means more than
likely that that score is going to be
high sixes to Middle sevens middle
probably middle sevens right right um
and maybe the story aspects taking it up
a notch more so again as PR you're doing
your job protecting the game protecting
the sales up until the point of launch
and at that point it's out in the world
and what people feel about it it's going
to be out there and people going to be
able to make their own decisions that's
what it is I jump in make this quick cuz
I know we go along on this one but um
you know it's one of those things that
the way I I've always been consistent
you know there's a lot of codes you know
weeded we haven't gotten as an outlet
and yeah there's disappointment I'm not
going to sit there the human element is
youo you're disappointed you want to
cover the game that kind of thing but
I've always been consistent that I I
feel like no one is entitled to a review
code that's at the discretion of the
developer the publisher and how they
want to handle it and to me it's like
you know we also have to deal with the
reality that and this is human nature
when sometimes when there is entitlement
for something that you are used to
sometimes human nature is necessarily to
your emotions may spill over and react
you know what I'm saying unfavorably to
that thing that you think you should get
so I get it I've been I've been there
some sometimes like yo we didn't get
that J you know what I'm saying and I
had to check myself like yo you ain't
you know what I'm saying you got you
ain't old nothing yo just keep grinding
eventually your time going to come so to
me this is not nothing new I do think
you know it's unfortunate obviously they
wanted to cover it you know what I'm
saying but it didn't happen but ain't no
biggie for me it's just like I hate to
be foul but it's like Welcome to the
Real World where everybody else is going
through it and again no one is intitled
they can do people can say oh well
they're cherry picking or whatever what
it's their right to do whatever they
want to do at the end of the day they're
in the business of trying to make this
game so the most copies get the exposure
they wanted to get and who would
influence her they true that's all num
and it's up to you that after it come
out for you to make decisions like now
this was still this was whack I see what
they do or afterwards you know what it
was good it was a little you know kind
of thing but that's where I'm at with it
anything else before we move on to the
next page we got two more uh we got uh
yeah do you want to just let me go with
we still got cuz we got like two long
Pat on questions but you yeah these are
these are three super chats some of them
yeah some of them they're specific to
this so uh let me see he your man $10
Super Chat oh hell the Great and
Powerful Lords I'm so happy that the
Lord's got to smell the flowers you
earned and deserved you turkeys better
be cool in the chat with my uncle dirt
WG TTS gang in this your mouth up
Hector gang gang bang
bang and that we got kit smoth remember
for 4 bronze did Destin cost IGN Suicide
Squad review codes if so can't that
impact his job there um
I I listen you guys mentioned Dustin so
he what did he say because I didn't hear
what he said specifically he what did he
say well I mean
paraphrasing the latest uh tweet looked
like it was kind of like yo we didn't
get it but you know at the end of the
day I'm still pulling for the game I
think the vibe I get there was some
backlash to the title of that review and
I think he's responding to that as well
as said hey we we still hope the game
does well or whatever does well right
okay so at the end look I don't know
that that can happen anymore right all a
lot of us who've been in the space a
long time know what happened with Jeff
gersman back in the day um he was at gam
spot yes he reviewed I think it was was
it army of two or something like
that and he gave it a bad score because
he said it was a bad game and um they
you know the publisher was not happy
with that EA right the publish EA I
believe it was EA yes yeah um we could
be wrong about the details of this but
what happened was that he ended up
getting fired over not wanting to you
know acquest to the demands of this
publisher giving them a better score um
that ain't happening anymore that that
was just a bad look all the way around
um so yeah uh I don't think that's going
to happen uh you got to be able to voice
your opinion on
something you you're gonna you're going
to catch the smoke from the internet
regardless to lose your job over
something like that that would cause a
big Hub up that I don't think I he's not
losing his job over there they say it
was Kanan Lynch Not uh not Kane and
Lynch Not R Kan and Lynch to right it
was Kan and Lynch to yeah yeah yeah kyn
I remember that yeah yeah so what do you
think the people are saying that like
you know they see some of these people
clearly either have like alternative
motives or they just not playing the
game and uh you know this is their this
is like the Publisher's way of like
shooting back I've been hearing that
yeah I listen we've
I I'll speak for myself I've heard
internally that Publishers some some
Publishers especially if they feel the
reviews are completely unfair or make
like really personal style attacks right
they've been making internal decisions I
have heard this and the way the way
things are being distributed we kind of
may be in a shift in way certain things
so just be on the lookout for that maybe
not every publish but some some is what
I'm all right well we have Lucius
Augustus $5 Super Chat and it speaks to
that a little bit I has a higher weight
on Metacritic so them rating the game
badly day one would tank the game even
if most Publications like like it meta
weight sucks I think there is truth to
this right where a bad IGN review is
probably the one that's at the top of
the list on Metacritic when you go
whether it's good or bad is probably the
one that's right near the top um and
that matters to a lot of people that
matters to a lot people they they they
put a lot of weight into that yeah what
you call it they said Strange Love said
you missed one of his super chats but
strange love yeah I think maybe
um you know when it comes down to like
bad bad takes and stuff like the only
time I have an issue with the reviews is
I I feel was a genuine as long as it's
genuine you know you got to deal with
the consequence I think this is one of
those scenarios where IGN rarely deals
with their reviews because they're so
big it's hard to really like just shut
them out but it's just like look if
that's IGN's legitimate issues with the
game then I'm cool with that now I don't
agree with Publishers like attacking
like not necessarily attacking like uh
penalizing companies for just giving a
bad review it's different from giving a
bad review to having alternative motives
[__] on a game I I think that's
different uh but as far as just like
look this game's not the greatest you
know we we really want different I think
that's okay but if there you know if
there's like some alternative motive you
know we we don't like suicide squad you
know or for instance you know they're
just giving it a bad review because it's
not uh you know the next Batman game I
do think that's one of the things where
okay that's messed up yeah pre pre
preview Impressions from probably the
biggest Outlet does affect things right
so we got to talk about the business of
it which is real but we got a lot to go
talk we actually there was a couple I
met did Miss JD gamer $2 Super Chat
Lions forever
baby Pride then we got fors of Legend $2
Super Chat Cog infinite wealth story is
amazing please finish oh he will yeah
trust me Tekken first almost there
started in we'll talk about then we got
Doctor Strange Love $5 Super Chat WB not
giving anyone review codes cuz they know
they have a nasty life service Lo
shooter stinker Cog I blame Destiny for
this what what what did Destiny hold
their reviews from anybody no stop
it we got JD gamer $5 Super Chat
pathetic for beging ponies got no games
and all those narratives keep falling
down shout out to dirt and Forte it's a
special day in the Deep yeah today Lions
baby oh that's right I got dirty I got a
oh man on the Rays in Detroit baby them
L I can't believe we're here man salute
to y'all salute to y'all facts time they
was in this I was 14 wow wow salute we
got the pride in the building what else
we got yeah I feel that then we got JD
gamer $2 Super Chat pathetic Port be
Pony's got no games # no PS holding it
holding it down for the general it is
absent for the general always JD gamer
style man JD gamer go hard y side with
it hold Advance the line we good CAU up
all right two more patreon questions we
got to go we get to the topics yet all
right uh us it I found hope all is well
in the realm my question kind of relates
to the recent cancellation of Odyssey
but it goes a bit beyond that for a long
time since even before redfall to be
honest we've heard people say that Xbox
needs to get more involved with the
studios they acquire and ensure the
games they are producing are up to stand
it this talk hit its peak when Xbox
began completely being completely
blindsided by redfall and its overreact
over overall reception and I saw a lot
of people saying stuff like what is Xbox
doing this should have been canceled if
this was PlayStation they would have
canceled it with the recent cancellation
of Odyssey could we take this as an
indication that Xbox is getting more
involved with the studios due to never
wanting a red fold situation to ever
come close to having happening again and
what potentially could that mean for the
future just to be clear I'm not saying
Odyssey would have been another redf or
anything close to it we don't know
enough about what the actual plans for
Odyssey were outside some of the basic
ideas to determine if Odyssey would have
been a good or bad game my question has
more to do with Xbox getting more
involved in the first place and what
that means going forward regardless hope
all the Lords in the chat have a great
rest of their Sunday so what about you
man what you feel about this Odyssey
situation that's a great question um so
I'm hearing that it it was an engine
issue right that
like going back to the the discussion
about Halo infinite right is that slip
space and sort of tech debt and not for
a game that you want to survive for many
years it seemed like they built it on
Tech that was not going to be able to
cut it years down the line and um so
that's what I'm I'm kind of reading
right now uh as an over like in kind of
an an overarching reason for it um
beyond that I mean just me inferring and
and assuming maybe this is just not when
you like when you think about like a
scale bound right and what happened
there it was like well the game's been
de in development for a long time maybe
where the game stood at this point and
the amount of money it would still
require to reach the Finish Line yep was
not something that they were willing to
to spend on that type of game coming
from now one thing that that would have
been interesting to see is that type of
game coming from blizzard right with
blizzard being just generally obviously
not in recent years but generally being
known for the quality of their games it
could have been a return to form right
may maybe that you could it could have
been seen that way but for whatever
reason do do I think it is kind of a a
reaction to them you know kind of
dropping the ball on redfall and sort of
the backlash they got off of that maybe
internally they're thinking like you
know what we need to look at this stuff
as early as possible this is six years
in the tank and now that we have to you
know we have access to look at it
because technically they couldn't look
at it before
um they made the decision that it wasn't
worth it to continue developing it and
spend whatever they needed to spend on
it to bring it across the finish line so
again uh who knows what what it would
have been who knows how far along it was
I saw some reactions from people on the
dev team um I think they this this Dev
team was one of the teams that was
really kind of gutted if I'm not
mistaken yeah pretty much so it's um you
know it it's sad for them and a lot of
people seem to be happy with what they
were creating so again we'll never know
at this point but um they made that
decision what is based off of again I I
get it I get it because it is that thing
of like we don't want to continue being
known as this company that keeps taking
bets on things that don't pan out and it
you know we next thing you know this
game has been in development for 10
years and it's still it's still not
great or still hasn't come out so I
understand um but it is tough because
they just kind of jumped in assessed and
made a decision on something that you
know was six years into making so that's
a tough thing tough pill to swallow for
sure no doubt 100% ad at
thoughts I think they're looking at the
landscape they're like look you know
it's far as like the survival games arcs
out there we have that in Game Pass
power world we have that in Game Pass uh
not to mention like what's not in their
ecosystem like you have to look at a
comp compet comption wise like this game
might take another three years to come
out what else we going to have to deal
with competitively by then uh you know
in terms of games and service in general
we already have the biggest ones in the
industry right now why keep investing
into something we might not even know if
it's going to do well or not uh so you
know I think they just it's like look
you know let's cut some of the fat stuff
that we don't necessarily need and I
think they looked at that game is we
don't necessarily need it let's get rid
of it D your thoughts on the Odyssey
situation very surprising yeah I agree
with both of um adct and sa because like
adct just said um you know the game was
apparently still like two to three years
out after six years of development
listen man they got to pay those people
that means the buzz is going to continue
to rise they made an executive decision
look like the game is probably going to
be a gamble they don't know if the game
will be a success like adex said you
just don't know it's a gamble um also
like I just mentioned the budget is
continuing to go up we don't know what
state the game was in was the game good
did Matt booty and his team say yeah
this game looks a little you know it
doesn't look that great these are tough
decisions and um that's why Matt booty
um is put in that position to make those
tough decisions you know they mentioned
you know F and Matt booty mention redf
how they was not handson enough with
red um and I believe you know R far
might have opened their eyes you know
they're giving these Studios the C blong
to do they want to do but at the same
time they got a babysit these projects
to make sure they don't have another
it's a business you know it it's a
business so they made the decision for
some reason like s said we probably
never know the exact reason but I'm
pretty sure all of the things that we're
saying here there might be a little bit
of all of that you know going on in the
play so yeah no well said I pretty much
agree with what you said dir and
everybody else's you know it's
unfortunate you know me just kind of
with soft said my only dis major
disappointment is I would have loved to
see like that jar from blizzard to see
how it is but you know to your point
Derek like if it was a situation where
they came to oversee and then you know
at basically in a post redfall world if
this is the new way that they operate
then it's like okay we need to see
what's going on and clearly we C cutting
cost if projects are going to blow up
balloon budgets and we don't think that
this is going to be a viable thing like
addict said in the um you know in in the
space so yeah those are the tough
decisions sometimes we got to look at
from the standpoint like we cannot as a
community consistently tell them to
quality control and then when they do it
say why' you cancel that that's a good
point to we don't know what condition
this game was in we probably never know
we never know if they canceled it and
they let something like red ball get out
the gate there's a good chance it
probably wasn't at their standard and
they don't want another right ball
happening absolutely it's sad we're
going to miss out a new on a new IP
right it's always sad when a new IP kind
of dies in in its incubation but what
are you going to do hey St that's a
point new IP in today's gaming climate
that's a gamble listen if you're making
GTA6 you can take 10 years to make it it
doesn't matter because you know that
game not a gamble it's not a gamble you
know that game is going to do extremely
well when it releases yeah this is the
new IP and the genre that's not really
you know uh huge
so it's a gy they said you know look man
we can't you know is cut it right now my
only issue probably is I completely
agree is that I'm like damn the whole
team got disant that was damn hard that
was unfortunate all right one last one
then we get to topics Benjamin uh he
said uh I think did we get this salute
to the um no actually I did not get this
salute to the four horsemen on another
fabulous day I bet Cog is loving the
fact that Nine's game is the Slate late
slot yes yes yes we've been talking
about this run via Twitter we're in the
home stretch enjoy the game brother
salute now on to the Gams with the slew
of games right now and the fact that
Yakuza infinite wealth will make it to
Game Pass in due time oh you predicted
okay do you think it's best to wait I'm
about halfway through the first like a
dragon stuck on the effing crane boss I
know where you at the riots didn't grind
enough and now I'm stuck in the battle
just wondering what sort of time you're
having it with the Cog heard the first
15 hours drag a bit debating whether or
not to just YouTube the rest of the
first game and move into Infinite wealth
time is precious he a finish time is
precious and I heard this game is less
grindy have a blessed Sunday and may it
be as pretty as those guns you got Wow
Let's Get this Bowl Ravens rematch is
written all right adct go ahead just
wait uh we we have a whole topic on on
on infinite wealth so uh to me I feel
like we should just you know talk about
this I agree I agree all I will say is
um yeah I stay still play the game play
the first one Beat It Go Back grind cuz
you should get caught up I don't don't
YouTube it man ich Bond deserve better
up anyway all right get the super chats
um poll and then me into these topics JD
gamer2 Super Chat adct
TTS yeah people missed adct show that's
what's going yeah yeah uh oh we got
there we got oh no it's Alex $10 Super
Chat blizzard ruined the IP that
literally made that company Diablo
Odyssey should have been canceled years
ago and Rod Ferguson should be out the
door with oh come on Alex not like this
I with you CL out the closer I with you
on everything until the last line that
was with you bro like and I defer to
your PC knowledge in the space on what's
going on with blizzard I defer to you
and jez when it comes to Blizzard cuz
they go hard as far as the PC space but
not Ferg Ferg big fer that's the closer
we can't do that that man got a
reputation for closing but I'm going
leave it alone you you may no know in
the space he said get out of here come
on Al not like this slap the thigh you
got to fix that anyway JD gamer what you
got JD gamer $10 Super Chat it's not
just about a post redfall world is the
fact that they now have enough Studios
and games in development where they can
make those choices to give us only the
real gems the same way PlayStation does
that is true I mean say quality the SL
the pickings ain't slim anymore so yeah
I mean something is
subpar you know and I I get that I
understand too cuz it's like hey I would
love for them to really get away from
that I
g g g Game Pass F seven you
know out exactly get that up what else
you got all right good all right cool
last week's post also end the people
spoken to the question with the
unbelievable success of the power world
launch should Xbox looks to expound upon
their current Game Pass game preview
relationship with pocket pair games the
winner of the ILP poll at 49% of the
vote was yes Microsoft should drop the
bag at all costs like Minecraft okay
they talking strong here in power world
coming in second at 34% of the vote was
wait monitor the success game is already
a Game Pass and in last place at 60% of
the vote was I don't care when Nintendo
lawyers get a hold of this is on site
shout out to the people who voted s this
kind of relates to your topic and so
they they want microf dro the B I hate
to be the bad be the bad news Nintendo
ain't doing nothing of this oh they
don't want that smoke say these balls
for the topic doing nothing this they
done
something say them balls for the topic
that's lit so all right U listen man
they need to drop that back this game
we're look tell me to save for the topic
well I cuz I just asked a question
question I just don't want to you was
about to go in I could feel you was
about to go in but I did you stop oh I
know okay I was like you you you you
saved me I just want to make sure that
was all yeah that that was the correct
move drop the bag at this point it's
fair to say that game is probably around
the 10 million sale Mark that's crazy
that's crazy yeah no listen and this Dev
team you could say what they you want
about about how you know how they go
about business they can still make a
game and if you sit down with them and
you sort of focus that road map on
really evolving this game into something
truly truly special removed from all of
the the Pokemon hubbub you got a winner
there and like I said
before Bill Spencer SRA Matt booty there
are two words they will never live down
uh
oh and that
is impact don't let that happen again
okay don't let that happen again got the
Rel Rel you have it already nurture it I
know may you know some of the things
you're hearing is like do I want the
smoke yes you want the smoke I'm sorry
fair enough Eddie super we get we can
start uh yeah we have hold on a second
we have SSU
Sage Red fall cat and Strays strong
combat strong weapons great sandb good
Powers beautiful visually top sound
design good writing it's fun uh I don't
know how many passes you had Sage Sage I
like look it wasn't there don't let me
stop your joy brother don't let me stop
your
J R I'm in R oh you you you in you in
all the way um it was good I mean it was
okay it wasn't their best work it wasn't
arc's best work but I but you know it
was okay okay so it's so that means it's
been improved I to be fair I have not
gone back I would I would since the 60
frames and I saw the AI still and
certain but we going to move on I don't
want to stop nobody you you enjoy
yourself brother it's all matter is you
love it better you than me exactly there
we go chy $10 Super Chat wait I did not
just hear Cog recommend playing the
earlier games in serious sorry K you
have to break down and play yaku six bro
heard anyone who's played them he's
talking about playing look here's the
thing like we ain't playing that
old nah we ain't doing that mystical
rope r r RAC
name salute salute to we good we good we
real good on that g good now this nice
turnbas stuff that we playing right now
yeah I recommend that guess what it's
only on like a dragon infinite wealth W
salute salute salute now salute to the
he goes hard for for K you the older hey
if y'all want to do that all like I just
said if you're completely new to the
series do not feel like you are in like
you are mandatory to do the other stuff
when it really is a fresh start with
yaka like a dragon so you have the choic
it's up to y'all but you know where I'm
at but you do recommend playing like a
dragon to completion before you yes I
recommend like a dragon completion now
if you want extra context and to get a
feel of the Y yakas again gam I rep
recommend um the man who eras his name
next it fills the Gap prequel to like a
dragon and then that'll lead you to
where they at now infinite wealth and I
will see KIRO story in in the man who
rac's name is fire especially at the end
man the man been through some things so
my beef with him is over but ich my man
continue then we got Miguel Ivars with
the five euro Super Chat everyone has
been crapping on activism blizzard for
years asking for changes and rightfully
so merger or no merger changes would
always lead to lay off
we going to get to it we almost there we
going get to it I don't know if it would
be this wide of a swath
of if it would they were just by
themselves but yeah but yeah change
requires uh not fun stuff to happen then
we got Hollywood rules M for 24 months
Lord silver happy Sunday my NYC and West
Virginia cousins abute tuned in to see
Tito Jermaine and Jackie so just cuz
Michael a here don't you do that we went
picked up Prince anyway we got dir there
you
go it's all good man y get what y'all
want
I I kid have a great show brother it's
great to see you guys with the Jackson 4
how dare you how dare you sir you don't
even get a number Jackson King them guys
King them them
dudes
disrespectful you got we have J Boy On
The Run $ five Super Chat click
clickbait is a double-edged sword the
big company's been doing this longer and
watch the media change and clickbait
it's clickbait is the top at the moment
cback ClickBank could do serious damage
yeah it could do serious damage and it
could also bring the numbers sometimes
the people don't care about the about
the damage reputation if the bank is
right and you know hey to each his own
chill Edie Cruz so they not coming to
see you all this I'm about to block you
hold
on disrespectful hey I told you about
that chat I told you and the crws are
watching you they're close to a timeout
don't
you that was they were like y'all don't
need to respond to King just let him
cook just let talk shut up I'm like
really this a it's called a podcast for
a reason oh man disrespectful I know I
know Edie I'm messing with you that was
funny let me see let me see then we got
JD Gabriel $5 Super Chat imagine an
golden seal of quality where they only
hitting 85 Plus on Metacritic and
they're dropping three to five of these
games per year I'm sure with all that
I'm sure they love that I'm with all
that right there what else you got then
we got Hollywood rules $5 super chat
about to jump into Championship Sunday
wishing car good luck on his ners salute
thank you got a root for Detroit being a
fellow have not Jets fan that's pain I
feel that Herman Mo Barry Sanders [__]
I used to rock with them i't got no beef
with the Lions I'm tell good understand
I understand I understand there's been
no greatness on the Lions I get it GG's
GG's hey dirt TTS out yo what's up bro
salute what else we got that's it we
caught up all right let's get into first
topic all right all right here we go so
this the big one y know what y here for
as s would say uh shout out to The Verge
shout out to Tom Warren one of the sites
that I see break it kind of early huge
man Microsoft lays off
1900 Activision and Xbox employees
blizzard president Mikey B has also
decided to leave and blizzard Survival
game Odyssey has been cancel so yeah
Microsoft is uh primarily laying off the
roles at ABK some Xbox and zenom Max
employees will also be affected by the
cuts the cuts work out to roughly 8% of
the overall Microsoft gaming division
that stands at around 22,000 employees
uh in total uh Verge had an obtained an
internal message from um Memo from uh
Phil Smith M regarding the layoffs
there's a lot here so I'm going to try
to parse um pretty much um they talked
about you know since the acquisition
they moving forward of ABK joining um
Microsoft and they said as part of this
process we made the painful decision to
reduce the size of our gaming Workforce
the gaming leadership team and I am
committed to navigating this process as
thoughtfully as possible the people who
are directly impacted by these
reductions have all played an important
part in the success of abk's and a Max
XBox team should be proud I'm going to
paraphrase um we will provide our full
support to those who are impacted during
the trans position including sance
benefits uh for and um benefits inform
formed by local employment uh laws he
goes on and said um looking on looking
ahead we will continue to invest in
areas that will grow our business
support our strategy by bringing more
games to more players around the world
although this is a difficult moment for
our team I confident as ever in your
ability to create and nurge the game
stories and worlds that bring players
together also Mikey Bor like I said one
of the major the president was uh laid
off he made a statement as many of you
know um actually this is Phil talking
about Mike excuse me um Mike previously
spent more than 20 years at Microsoft
now that he's seen the acquisition
through he has decided to leave the
company and um this was actually
actually this was said by Matt Buie I
apologize in in a letter and then U Mike
uh Ibara had a statement he want to
thank everyone who's impacted by the uh
the layoffs and um for their mean
meaningful contributions to their teams
blizzard and players Liv so he had a
long statement in reference to that and
in finality um yeah this month has been
really rough this is the same month with
these Microsoft cuts that we got riot
games Google discord twitch unity and
eBay and others all this month so this
rocked the on netork January yeah this
is January I think there's statistic
already out we're almost at least
halfway we're at the halfway point of
what was uh the people amount of people
laid off in the totality of last year so
yeah this this wasan yeah this was
King's topic man so set it off for him
um I damn I'm really curious what he had
to say but let's start let's start with
start with dirt man dirt you know when
this news broke you know what's your
thought process now that you also have
time to process it more where you at
with all the layoffs well you know like
anybody else it's it's unfortunate man
you know like you mentioned the gaming
industry just the month of January 6,000
layoffs bro that's that's crazy man
that's the number that's going around
6,000 layoffs of course that includes
Microsoft recent layoffs and you know
it's it's terrible man um I think a lot
of us well most of us knew when the
merger of this scale would happen there
would be some layoffs but I didn't think
it would be this many you know 1900 is a
is a pretty big number man so that's a
big number bro so um like I said it's
unfortunate um you know things are going
to change you know there's a lot of
positions um that's that's that's
overlapping you know like according to
Phil and some other people um so you
know layoffs are bound to happen but
damn I mean this is uh it's it's pretty
rough man you know and right now the
gaming industry um we're seeing so many
layoffs I don't know if it's it's from
covid you know the after effects of Co
you know a lot of people hired during Co
and you know unfortunately you know
things aren't as hot as it was during Co
when everybody stuck in the house overal
yeah absolutely I was listening to
Randon Jazz and I believe like anybody
CH help me if I'm wrong but I believe
ran said when Microsoft announced the
acquisition of ABK ABK had like 10,000
employees but by the time the
acquisition was finalized they had
17,000 employees please anybody help me
if I'm wrong I got you like cor me up
wrong but I think that's what he said
and if that's true wow they hired a lot
of people in these two these 18 months
that this uh acquisition was going
through so like I said it's unfortunate
that happened um things always you know
need to change um and it's just terrible
that it has to be at the expense of
these workers yeah and like in the like
back in the day when we heard layoffs we
could say oh man they can get a job with
another gaming company you know the
gaming industry is flourishing you can't
really say that anymore like you you
just can't man I mean so many layoffs
from every like last year we saw Sony
Bungie we saw some other people this
year just January Microsoft themselves
and and unfortunately Co I don't think
this is the last of it no it's not and
I'm going to be very clear I'm glad you
said that because generally when I get
to my I get more in detail but generally
this is the first culling of usually a
series of like two or three they usually
do them in waves so if people think this
there's more to come to be clear not not
to be laughing but no I agree I agree
continue continue yeah yeah yeah no I
mean no I mean that's it um it's just
all you know like the game industry is
making money obviously but it seems like
it's very topheavy
you know we have those fortnites we have
the Call of Duties the Minecrafts you
know we have you know those those
certain games those four or five games
that's there we know GTA 6 is going to
be a monster when that releases um but
there there's the other ones right the
the games that people you know do you
want to even gamble to make this game
it's not gonna you know make enough
money so I really feel that the you know
like hellblade to like we hear that type
of game it's a game made by maybe 40
something people short short experience
8 to 10 hours whatever is going to be I
believe that's going to happen more
often we're going to see less um
Assassin's Creed Val hollas and more
Assassin's Creed mirages you know I just
feel that the gaming industry is a man
it's so rough right now and me I'm a
gamer before I'm an Xbox Fanboy right
I'm a gamer I want the industry to
flourish and I just want people to
realize we we're going to get less of
these huge
triaa games excuse me of course there's
always going to be exceptions but we're
going to get less with these type of
games and um these layoffs it is just an
indication in my opinion that things are
changing man and I think we need to
realize things are changing in this
industry bro yeah well well said and I
think to support what you were saying in
reference to how the industry is
changing you mentioned the hellblade you
mentioned what I was thinking about when
you said that I was thinking about the
Insomniac leaks and how Sony was looking
at the budgets and saying these 300
million these are just expensive and
then they were saying you know like cuz
one of the big surprises with h blade
right was the $50 price point we were
like that's interesting digital only
right digital only that's again not
saying everybody's doing that but it it
could be the way Microsoft's thinking
right it could be the way that hey maybe
you make it's not the 20 hour you make
the the 6 to8 and I think even with the
insic like they mentioned you know
splitting potentially Spider-Man 3 into
two parts at $50 price point so maybe
signs right so good point let's get the
atct man my brethren we were talking
about this you know this week and you
know huge layoffs now they got a chance
to settle what's your thoughts about all
these layoffs going down at
Microsoft uh oh all right he's got
something on let me let me blow it up
he's got something on his screen I've
never had one of these little like extra
things that you buy
for it's fire I like that this actually
like makes cuz I've never really been a
handheld person mhm but putting these
like makes this the handheld a lot
easier to play like I think when the
switch two comes out I'm going just
immediately get like one of these side
things even though this is not the
switch to Top This Microsoft you playing
during top but it's
cool it's my turn to talk it's your turn
to talk you finish playing interrupt you
for the topic yeah so yeah I think when
it comes down to this you know I think
it's just B semantics and like there
there's more
there's more than just like ABK people
that got laid off there was like a lot
of community managers that got laid off
and it's just like first off putting
away the layoffs themselves like it's
not a good industry and a good thing to
be in like imag like let's put away the
people that have been laid off imagine
the people that
survived and they're
like I made it this time but I'mma make
it next time
and it would be different at this if any
industry not just this industry handled
layoffs better like more Humane they
just like when you it's like any day you
can log on and your login ain't working
any day you can go in your card key
ain't going to turn on and to me the
layoffs ain't even the biggest issue the
biggest issue is how the industry
handles them if you knew four facts that
you that you that that you you are good
you're going to be handled correctly
you're going to know ahead of time you
should have three months of knowledge
before your three months of of it
happening because obviously most of
these people probably got like a
three-month package to leave or a month
package depending on how long they've
been there you should you should have
three months before that time even
starts yeah like you should at least
have the knowledge to know that in three
months you will not be employed anymore
so you can at least do ahead of time on
scouting and like the the fact that they
don't give them that like they they will
want you have two week notice but they
get ready you in a day it makes it just
like look like how do they expect this
industry to grow I would say right now
don't get in the gaming industry if
you're in college invest your time in
any industry but this industry because I
feel like this industry is the most like
destructive implosive industry you could
see it's just like you know bad
semantics when you go out and
spin 78 billion dollars on industry but
I think they did the math it was like
250 million to keep uh the majority of
the jobs it's like so it's not even a
billion dollars to keep them and I get
it at the end of the day you know these
people weren't essential to what they
want in the future but it's just like
it's like I said it's not even the the
layoffs the issue it's how they handled
it it's like we wake up on a random
Monday and find out these people are
getting laid off I don't know if it was
Monday or not but you guys get what I'm
saying it's like I don't like that
yeah you know and not to mention there
was a community manager that posted and
it really hit me was like I survived
this but now every time I wake up am I
next imagine living in an industry like
that and if you go look and there's
another Community match of the for uh
fallout uh I guess 76 I don't know and
it said on there it said she
said that she was let go and if you go
score like three or four four before
that she said I'm going to be in this
job forever yeah oh wow it's like three
or four days she she and then it it just
was crazy like
yeah you look at I think it was someone
said that they survived they were like
one of the higher end people they have
no one left on their their
team people on their team just had kids
just bought
houses and then just gone it's like to
me it's like geez man like I understand
you know it's not Microsoft's fault how
you invest into your into your personal
life but it's like at the same time I
see people saying it's illegal to let
them know I don't care if it's illegal
then that needs to change like because
there's no way that Microsoft woke up on
a Monday and said get rid of all these
people they've known for weeks to months
so why can't they let the other people
and I get it the perception you gonna
get that bad perception regardless you
know you cannot sit here and expect
people to to go in there with the
mindset that we're going to make some
great games for you but then we gonna
let you all we goingon to let you go
right after the thing that sucks is that
after the merger there were a lot of
people that were really hopeful at
blizzard you know what I'm saying and
just like yo now I mean let's be real
once once Bobby you know was out and
then a lot of people felt I you saw the
sentiment right you saw the pictures and
we saw we like yo you know they're
really feeling confident about what's
going to happen and that's the
unfortunate part when is you defin like
you said adct like those people don't
survive and they still you know get
caught up in the mix and the crossfire
as part of that but I'll let you finish
if you and people look there's no excuse
for this like look these probably had to
happen regardless lot of repeat jobs etc
etc but at the same time it's like
what's the point of
buying you know one of the biggest
things that they said they want to buy
Publishers is cuz they have their own
infrastructure they have their their own
uh PR they have their own way of doing
marketing guess what a lot of these
people lost their job duplicate stuff
for Microsoft to
Activision but if they're doing all that
and they bought them because they had
those infrastructures in place what was
the point of buying them they were just
gonna offset all that all that work back
onto Microsoft no I I get what you're
saying but I mean we we have to talk
about we do have to mention redundancies
are common not that I'm trying to
minimize but my point of doing this is
because they
there wouldn't be too many more
redundancies because they actually want
them to to run on their own
independently right but they're still
part of the lar when you're required
though you are still part of the you do
buy them to that degree because you want
them to run on their own but then you
you how I don't know how many was let go
of just Activision in ABK but it might
must have been at least half at least
half I think majority was yeah so it's
like let's just say 3,000 and that that
you know it's just well 1900 people got
let go but it's just like 6 700 people
maybe it's just to me I get the
redundancy thing but it's like but but
you literally go on and say you want to
buy these companies because you want
them to run on their own because of
these positions and then you say you
need to let go of them because there's
redundancies but that's the whole point
that you invested in them because they
can run on their own so to me if you're
going on with this kind of statement
there wouldn't be many redundancies
because they're actually do that is the
counterpart in Activision and then
there's a counterpart in Microsoft and
the whole point I'm buying Activision
Blizzard King is because you're going to
keep the counter version of Activision
because he's going to ride Activision
like yeah what the thing that makes it
surprising is it's to your point in
addition to the redundancies there were
a ton of other jobs let go that also
even outside of ABK right and outside so
you had all this the sheer volume of the
number plus things that were outside of
it right was like you know um what is it
the entire Xbox physical Division I
think was was hit about hit about this
and then um zamax was also part of this
there were other community managers like
that's not redundancy no absolutely and
clearly not saying it was only
redundancies I'm just saying is that to
your point it was redundancies and all
these other things and the [__] numbers
so I hear where you coming from let's
get um s man I guess
people are saying oh clueless adct you
could be clueless all you want I'm here
you're not so calm the hell down sit in
the chat with with with with your stuff
and your little pinky out while you
drink whatever you drinking look I'm
just talking from my perspective when a
company says that they want to buy
another company because they can handle
the stuff that they're doing and they
don't have to rehire people and have
them all all they don't have to delicate
all of that all those jobs on a
Microsoft that's the key point to buying
Publishers because they already have the
infrastructure but how is there a lot
more redundancies when that was the
whole point in buying them because they
have the marketing already intact
because they have the community me the
community aspect already intact because
they have the executive roles already
intact to me there would be less
redundancies because that's the way the
company functions now uh dirt said they
went from 10,000 and 19,000 so maybe
they're cutting fat off of that uh but
to me like I understand
that this is part of the industry that's
fine that's why I said I'm not really
too upset on the the layoffs per se I'm
upset how they handled them you know you
can't expect this industry to grow if
any minute you wake up and you can't
even get in your they don't got at least
in some ways people would sit there
there'll be a meeting at some point I
remember I worked at dish once and they
were uh I got laid off from there and
they they were literally laying people
off you you got to tap on the shoulder
if you had if you're getting laid off
that's wow that's how you found out wow
they tapped on your shoulder and told
you Goose yo you said they
duck was is is is you you're on call and
if you got on Tapped on the shoulder and
told you to route your call to a manager
you were gone that's how you found out
and then gave you a cardboard box and
told you get out of here they no they
told you to grab your personal
belongings with you and then after they
got up and you walked away some dude was
in a box and put your stuff in a box and
and gave it to you outside they
literally escorted you out the building
out of the building yeah yeah yeah to me
that is the issue with layoffs there's
zero humidity in this yeah they don't
give you any opportunities to Pivot they
don't give you any opportunities to
figure out what you're going to do next
you're gonna find that they're like okay
we're going to give you this package and
it's going to be good for a month or
three months in a lot of ways especially
if you want to go back in the game
that's not enough time and why would
anyone go from the gaming industry to
another company in the gaming industry
with some of these people most likely
been laid off multiple times there's no
job security what is that result in D
that results in but add I heard I'm
sorry I'm sorry let me say I heard that
uh they didn't tell the people the
employees that were being laid off ahead
of time because of uh leaks or or like
they didn't want out there before it was
officially going to be announced um not
saying it's right I'm just what what I
heard and I feel you but that that news
is going to come out eventually so right
there shows they value a little bit of
better PR and how they handle than they
like than they value the people that's
getting laid off and I get it I'm not
running a trillion dollar cup I don't
know anything about this but to me I
think if you want to maintain morality
because because like I said you are
literally it's like put away the people
that's been laid off give the mindset
the people that's there they ain't
really working like that right now
they're like first off they the next
couple days they're going to take on how
this is happening and then what's going
to happen DT then they're going to start
talking on am I next right oh next week
am I getting laid off next month am I
getting laid off how do you work in that
mentality how do you work in that kind
of housew work in that kind of work
environment it definitely sucks bro
definitely yeah the only thing I will
say in being that environment too is
that we also have to think about and
let's be clear there are also people
that if they know that information pull
it up in a negative way and we got we
got to be real about that there there's
there's no perfect way in my opinion to
handle it and I'm not justifying what
they did I'm not doing that this is
terrible I agree this is awful like
there's no cosigning I'm just saying
that I'm just telling you the way
corporations think is that they have to
have security protocols in place because
if dudes W out it's you now you talk
about a a situation and then you're
talking about okay now I know oh I'm
going to take data with me I'm going to
do this I there been known you you
sometimes you have that angry guy that's
like yo I ain't leaving you going to
pull me from the the moment the moment
the moment they let you go you are a
liability to right it's a retaliation
from a legal I feel like for the most
part that's going to happen regardless
you're going to have people flipping out
I ain't leaving d right there on the
spot uh you know I feel like that's
that's inevitable there's nothing they
can do to stop that you can have better
security cuz you know what's going to
happen but to me there there's no
difference between people that's a lot
of people that's a lot of
people talk stor the gates bro are we
are once again do we care more about the
semantics on the industry or the people
working in the industry to me I feel
like we I I I feel like look it might be
hard but there's got to be a better way
of course got to
be people care about people corporations
don't care about people and I feel on
that but at the same time I'm not saying
we're giving them excuses but I'm I'm
pretty sure the chat loves giving them
excuses and I ain't giving them I'm not
in uh the the I'm not in the business to
give them excuses what they're doing
sure business-wise it makes sense
there's probably a lot of jobs that need
be covered the layoffs itself isn't the
issue it's how they're handling it to me
is the issue I feel you oh yeah I mean
I'll get to my I'll get to my point but
um I was going to say I want to hold it
hold this up crazy lot to talk about so
your thoughts on the um this whole thing
man 1900 Microsoft I just think the
number took people a back right and um
because it's a huge number but I mean if
we think about what they acquired right
and we think about the idea of
redundancies and knowing they were going
to be redundancies and knowing that
there were they were going to always be
layoffs um I just think we didn't nobody
stopped to think about hey they they
took on this many people this brings
their total number to
22,000 any number of people they let go
in in in wide sads after after acquiring
this huge company was going to be a
number that we weren't going to be happy
with it was going to be a number that
was going to be eye opening and 1900 is
that number to start right um and I
think when you think about it in the
context of of who they are how big they
are and who they Acquired and how big
that company is it it it makes sense I
know right you know adct doesn't a agree
with some of these positions that that
went and I just think anytime that they
have these sort of layoffs they also
just assessing the value of other things
it's not specifically only what they
just brought in and seeing the obvious
redundancies people that more than
likely they're going to keep the person
they already had as opposed to the
person they brought in that's doing the
same job right so we know that um and
then internally it just gives them an
opportunity to clean house with things
that aren't being efficient and not
making money or you know kind of in even
if down the road they feel like they're
going to be doing work that we need or
whatever in the moment it do you know it
makes sense to them to get rid of them
and that's just the nature of business
that's how these things operate so y it
is super unfortunate that this happened
in this way
um but it was nothing that was
unexpected um the things that are kind
of that stick out to me about it are um
the Mikey bar leaving yes and the um the
Allan stupid he says it sucks the adding
laid off King
though and then obviously the the
co-founder of Blizzard um Alan Adam was
his name is that also yeah yeah that was
big um and I think what's interesting to
me about that is that there's a lot of
speculation about hey he decided to walk
away hey he was let go he was pushed out
especially after certain statements that
he made beforehand saying like
I'm here for the Long Haul just that's
what Jason quoted him for Jason shrier
quoted him for saying that so clearly
this man to your point off wanted to
stay so he said yeah he said the bar
told me that he wanted to stay for long
so Ione have to drag me out of Blizzard
that's how long I want to be here this
was back then that was back then so when
you think about it that first if you're
if you're the head of blizzard and you
know that all the all these people are
getting let
go I don't think you go online and say
hey this is my last day too I think you
stay there think the tact was okay right
because so again it goes back to the
point like he might have been pushed out
because for him to leave at the same
time as all of his employees are leaving
that you would think he would stay to
sort of Aid in their transition in any
way shape or form and to say hey I'm out
of here too I'm going to take some time
and travel the world which felt which
felt a little toned deaf and and a lot
of people let him know that that was
toned deaf of him
um it it just it kind of makes me think
that he was pushed out in some way shape
or form that he went in and you know
Microsoft had a different thinking about
where they want to take blizzard and
than what he did and you know since Mike
got there he pushed Diablo out the door
he pushed Diablo infinite out oh was it
infinite yeah that that a lot of people
were not happy with uh OverWatch 2 came
out which a lot of people were not happy
with um so he's made some decisions
there that have been uh a little
controversial but there's no question
that he was he loves blizzard right
so it is one of those things where it
just feels like hey whatever Matt booty
and and Phil Spencer you know have in
store for for for blizzard it wasn't
sort of on the same page as as what
Mikey bar wanted to do same for the
co-founder Allan Adam where it was like
hey this is a guy that was there when
blizzard was was at the top of its game
where it was like hey we have Starcraft
we have Warcraft then we have wow then
we have Diablo we have when blizzard was
Untouchable and everything they touched
was gold and for that guy to walk away
or be pushed out it's obvious that
Microsoft came in and said hey we have a
plan for what blizzard is going to be
moving forward and if you're on bored
with it fantastic we'd love to have you
if not then maybe it's time to walk away
or or as a co-founder right you walk you
said hey I don't like where this is
going I'm walking away um but again
looking at that situation specifically
with alen Dum it is a thing where okay
you're the guy that that was at the at
one of the guys at the helm of Blizzard
when it was at at the top of his game
you're also the guy that allowed it to
get to where it is now right so
somewhere along the line the the
idealism of of the blizzard that you
created went down the toilet with a bag
right when you when you went to
Activision and blizzard you know most
people feel that blizzard kind of
started going down in terms of quality
in terms of just everything that they
were putting out um so it could just be
that they they want fresh eyes Fresh
Faces in there to take blizzard in the
direction that Microsoft feels it needs
to go I just want to interrupt one one
quick second cuz I hear what you're
saying and that could very well be the
case but only isn't it surprising like
they it felt like at blizz call it felt
like this united front it really did
visually they put out like a p so that's
what surprised me because I'm like damn
I thought Mike was staying I thought
that you said you said united
front oh D that was a ball that was a b
but but no I agree with like yo these
guys are businessmen they're media
trained you could be burning up inside
and if what you have to do at the moment
is put on a good face and get this done
and then walk out and you know curse
somebody out behind the scenes and walk
out the door it it could definitely be
that again when Mike when Mike left
Microsoft we we were sort of thinking
about what was that about was it the
fact that you know look I've been in
this company for a long time I I feel
sort of suffocated by you know the
levels of management that I have to sort
of go through I get to write my own
ticket here at blizzard and do with this
company that I love whose games love I
get to be at the helm and make the
decisions it could also have been let's
say he wasn't pushed out right it could
also be hey I was here before I know
what this hierarchy looks like I know
what how they operate I don't want to be
part of that
anymore I don't want to have to answer
to anybody uh when it comes to you know
the bottom line what happens with this
company what happens with the games that
this company produces so that could be
that could be a a scenario as well but
the only thing that kind of makes me
wonder in the other direction is that if
you're the boss and you have the option
to leave when you want I don't see you
leaving at the same time as your entire
you know a swas of your staff are
getting laid off when you're supposed to
be there as support to help them
transition hopefully into other things
so it's weird that you're bouncing with
them like yeah I see y
twoo out I'mma travel the world by the
way let me let me the chat what look
people are like
oh fighting oh CH who you fighting with
I understand why layoffs happen the way
they are for security purposes for you
know uh stealing purposes that's not my
concept that's not my my battle I'm
telling you the way things are done now
I feel like there is a better way I
don't know the better way but but to
just to sit here and be like are we good
like no this is not look you can
understand how a process works and still
disagree with the way it's done like
people see her act like just because I
disagree with the way they lay people
off means like I'm like there's not a I
don't understand no I understand what's
going I just don't agree with that
that's way you act um so and and and
some of the reactions to some devs who
were still at the company or some devs
that were also laid off to him leaving
um were sort of like good ridd I saw
that see I saw that I was surprised by
that did you see someone that they're
like mikaru is the reason Bethesda and
the reason was yeah I saw mean about
blizzard he said he said 98% of the
issues with uh blizzard was was Mikey
bar it'd be crazy when people leave like
the like people feel more comfortable
saying stuff and you find out like the
real laundry in that company like well
that's the thing right I mean you never
really know the dirty laundry Jon
already alluding that it's book coming
he got yeah
ohri funny we'll have it back in with a
book I was going to say it I was going
to say it last week I was like yo shri's
been quiet I haven't heard I haven't
heard a news drop from shrier and then
this happened all M thing happened
someone said interesting Jason that
seems like it's going to be a chapter to
a book in here somewhere and he goes
sure is oh he's already cooking he's
already he's got the he's got the dirt
we already he's cooking so again sad all
overall um it's interesting because
again a lot of these a lot of these
Talking Heads that are leaving now yeah
leaves a void we're going to find out
who the new head of of got to get next
week yeah they got to get a pres so um
and again now the onus is on
Microsoft completely to to guide this
company forward right it was always on
them right but to addict's point if you
leave the entrenched management and you
let them operate as a silo that is
already in place it's on you to again
look at the games and be like hey this
is this quality yay or nay but now with
all of that sort of cleaning house at
the upper level
now it's on you to fill it in with
people that are going to bring blizzard
back to the prominence that people
expected to be at right that's the
expectation um and if you fail at that
then you're going to catch you're going
to catch fire catch work like oh you
bought them you ruined
them oh for sure let me let me jump in
if you good so M look oh man this right
here was wild crazy this week um I think
for me it's the number like you see
1,900 on the screen even though it
represent 8% it's like yo that's a lot
and then again the surprise you know
Mike you know I've been on record
multiple times during the acquisition
and yes I still standing on I was
cheering for the acquisition because I
still felt one it wasn't a legal
violation that they were the third place
company trying to get into the game you
want to point out that I called that
Mike part after the acquisition yeah and
and it's like my my thing was just like
I looked at the alternative and I know
people like yo what about y'all cheering
on or me cheering on now my thing is I
always look at the alternative we
understood the conditions at ABK during
the era was not good whether it be from
the sexual stuff whether it be from
people feeling that they were churning
out you know Call of Duties and sweat
machine like it was a lot of negative
thing and people felt overworked so the
thought process coming in it's like okay
at least they Bobby leaves he gets his
golden parachute but then we see what a
new era of and that the shocking thing
is cuz we see
the like said the unified front which is
like yo it's going to be a new day and
here's how it's going and people are
exciting and then bam this happens right
so this this really hits hard and for me
on a personal level I think adct made a
point you know I've just got to give y
some corporate cars the thing like bro
it sucks because it's two mindsets if
you you know something's coming cuz the
email will come in internally from
corporate right and they will be be like
yo for those remote or what or what stay
home right don't come into the office
that day kind of thing and what ends up
happening is which is the part that
really sucks is for some who are
affected or you receive is an email you
may get a call you know what I'm saying
but that's rare usually get the email
saying this is the next steps this is
where you deposit your things you know
what I'm saying and it's brutal you know
what I'm saying and to ask point if you
survive it's still sucks because now
whatever internal messaging system you
use to communicate with everybody in the
corporation oh I go look for D oh dirt
grayed out D damn homie gone like so
like you see you email someone and it
bounces back it's like you see the pho
snapping right in your eyes in real time
and it's just like yo like the reality
hits and then the meeting afterwards
okay these people are no longer here
this is the plan move for it's a cold
world it's cold bro like I I get it and
I'm sorry you going to jump in on
something oh you good I was to say maybe
like a wave handling this is see that
that that leads to stuff too you know
it's prematurely like uh because I know
there's probably companies like Head
Hunters that's like you know we're about
to lay off and give them a list of
people it's like you know could these
people potentially have a a you know a
job somewhere like no it sucks that's my
thing it's want I want the industry to
thrive more and to me I feel like this
is going to get worse and the talent is
going to just leave let me get there
here's the thing here's the thing and
this is where we align where it's like
the human element and then look the
gaming industry is we hear about all
these
profits the game IND is biggest as it
ever be ever it is but it can't retain
its workers it can't retain and we got
we got to talk about in my opinion and
I've been saying this for while what we
and I think the source is and I think
Sol alluded to it I mean Dirk you
alluded to it which is you know
corporations we got to be real when
covid happened and you had all of these
new people who are now joining the games
industry or playing games for the first
time so now you're seeing record profits
yo look at what we're getting look at
all the money we're making this is the
games are selling the engagement is
crazy and this is incorrect this is not
just this is everybody everybody correct
forecasting thinking that this is the
new normal from this point on so yo we
got to hire we going to have all this
growth we got to accommodate all this
growth we going to B and then what
happens right now Co starts to dissipate
people now start to get out into the
world and all these quote unquote
permanent new Gamers you thought you had
they are not there they back outside to
the club facts they in the club so now
you
overcompensated and you sitting there
and here's the reality that nobody want
to talk about I wish King was here for
this he probably be so mad with me but
the reality is when you have these level
of cuts in my opinion I don't have
Microsoft's internals but to me that
states that you are not meeting your
targets and you have to make these cuts
for the most part to survive and this is
across everybody this the same thing we
found out with Sony and bungee situation
we were like yo how could Sony do this
to Bungie or Bungie do this to their
employees they laid off mic they laid
off the composer they laid off all these
probative people community and then what
happened 2 weeks whatever later when the
financials came out we found out
immediately they didn't hit their
targets by over 45% so the hold on one
second the only thing is now is the
alternative you if you try to keep these
people on this is the reality now you
are may not go you you are not going to
survive as a company and we got to be
real the days of what Nintendo did that
guy that was honorable where he's like
I'm going to take a stakeholders going
to take a pay cut sh Hunters ain't
taking no pay cut we got to keep it a
buck here right that's the cold reality
and the sad thing about the games
industry is because of this the people
who actually put the corporations on
their back and made the Gams and made
the experiences they're the ones that
suffer to your point out I give it to
you the thing that sucks is we love this
games industry so much but the
volatility is so bad it is so bad you
got yeah and I'm with you we've had
developers on you know that talk about
they gave up prominent 9 to FES moved
their whole life to La move their whole
life to where the games industry at then
you uproot and then to find out boom
your fight that's it and now you got to
figure out what your next move like it
sucks it sucks so to to finish my point
you know this is to me again a result of
industrywide
forecasting um this this is bad man this
is bad like we as a games industry it's
got to get better but the sad reality is
we're already at that number at the
halfway point in month one of 2024 and
the other reality is that we got to
admit which is we probably like at least
another year of this this is not slowing
down like this this is still a thing and
and the last thing I don't know how y
guys feel I'll give it back to you guys
is you know I seen the CWA make a
statement the communications workers of
America and talking about unionization
and they were like look anyone that you
know workers that we represented wasn't
affected is this now a push I don't know
the solution but is this now a push for
more unionization in IND stre for more
job security you know what I'm saying in
that sense and it just sucks I'm just
tired of it to be honest with you and
this is everybody so I know a lot of the
you know gang gang bang bang is like yo
get Microsoft I'm giving everybody to
smoke this is not this should be
happening in the gaming industry with
all of this problem but I've been
talking yeah Microsoft I was say
Microsoft does not want to lay these
people off Mantic points a numbers thing
it just it sucks because you know this
isn't just a gaming industry thing this
isn't just a Microsoft thing this I mean
this isn't like my issue too is you can
have a mad successful IP yeah like like
a
fortnite go mad out you still have a
successful game like
Spider-Man we heard inic leaks they they
have to find out leak yeah that they're
going to get like that's crazy tell your
that's my goal is like why would these
people do what they're doing there's no
rewards for anything there's no okay as
long as we do well we do what we're
supposed to we're going to get rewarded
now you still going to let go like to me
where does that lead but down bro same
month Riot games Google discord twitch
Unity eBay and Microsoft one month crazy
man and we already at the half this is
crazy CRA you know so there's a young
lady that work for double find I
mentioned this on my podcast the other
day her name is LTE Montgomery black
woman she had drock pretty young lady um
she she's very vocal about the game
industry she's no longer working for
double fine she mentioned on her Twitter
how working on psychon 2 was like
difficult on her you know just the
constant crunch or whatever the issues
was working with double remember her she
was in one of the vidx I think so but
continue yeah yeah yeah yeah so she's
very critical of the gaming industry
every time there's some layoff she will
tweet something um you know saying
pretty much I'm paraphrasing here was
saying pretty much see see told y'all
you know something's not right with the
gaming industry and um you know I don't
know we don't know what's going to
happen we don't know um um what's the
cure like you guys just mentioned
fortnite epic steel laid off people yeah
Spiderman too it s like still laid off
people yeah so this is a gaming industry
thing not just a Microsoft PlayStation
you know like Microsoft is obviously the
latest oh yeah yeah um but this is a
gaming industry thing you know and and
us as Gamers um you
know it is what it is and hopefully it
ends but I don't know man you just don't
know at this point last point I saying I
give you off too I just want to say
we've been talk we we have friends
behind the scenes and I remember having
a conversation last year if you remember
at Pax West with a certain individual
and the comments was like yo I think we
had it for a games industry crash and at
the time I was like nah you Buck a no
and I'm not saying it's definitive but
it's clear the way the structure of the
industry is right now yeah clearly
something's about to happen I don't know
what got
to again I don't want to just sit here
and just write without Solutions but is
it you know what dur say is this now
where we get the smaller games you know
what I'm saying so to speak you know
with the triaa budgets are just sort
getting out of control you know is it
oversaturation right we're just too many
games and I think that's part of the
reason you're seeing consolidation to
the degree is because it's like one of
the only things to to help with what the
industry is going through right now is
to latch on to something bigger that has
more money so maybe you know the games
you know are again as not as just like
thrown out and just overwhelming you
where now things are spaced out because
it's clear like I said again the sonc
leaks gave us some hints you know we see
the blade situation it's going to be
curious to see how Microsoft mov for
just the gaming industry in general how
they move forward what you think so I'll
let you close before we move on um I do
yeah I agree with with everything you
guys are saying I do think we're still
in the throws of everything leveling off
after covid right Co covid gave us an
exaggerated situation where not many
Industries uh thrived during covid in in
the way the gaming did everybody was
home and it started happening before
they even realized it was happening like
wait a minute everybody's home people
who would never play games or get game
systems are like blew up side door Dash
de well door Dash I contributed to the
funds what
Dash
because instacart instaart went listen
man Amazon all that you in if you sho
instacart you were eaten D door Dash
probably sits around C's neighborhood
just waiting for him
I may or may not have contributed you
know what I'm saying black dude in this
this black dude in this building he T
real
good hey man door Das had me getting two
Subway sandwiches spending $35 on two
full on subway s and it's 5 minutes from
my house 5 minutes for the [__] you like
y like no I ain't going out no I'm not
doing that I ain't going out man no yo I
see dudes even now I see dudes like in
front of let's say a Chick-fil-A you got
10 dudes waiting there for the orders to
come in wow all they do all day is
deliver Chick-fil-A they don't even have
to go to other stores that's it
Chick-fil-A there Chick-fil-A that's it
that is that is their career as a door
Dash Chick-fil-A deliverer um crazy it's
crazy so all of these companies grew uh
an exorbitant amount and in an unnatural
way at an unnatural pace and now it's
all leveling off right so and you know I
can see the fact that it's not happening
it's still happening slower than I I
assume people uh are were expecting it
to happen where it's like oh you know
there's this you see it and you're like
oh wa there's something really wrong
with the game industry and and there
there are things that need to be changed
and addressed but I think a lot of it is
also is these companies trying to figure
out if they can they can move forward
being larger entities without having to
get rid of as many people and they go
longer and then they realize they can't
and all of a sudden you see oh we had to
cut 20% of our Workforce and we're going
to keep seeing that we're going to keep
seeing that until there is this leveling
off in that regard right but once that
is all said and done the problem of
exorbitant development costs is still at
the Forefront of why this stuff is
happening and to dirt's point I really
do think that we start we're going to
start seeing the more more mirages we're
going to start seeing more games like
Prince of pers the Los selling for $50
right um weal we talked about uh last
week uh Hey Oh last week or the week
before um hey hellblade 50 bucks in
digital only Allan Wake 50 bucks digital
only 60 bucks right 60 bucks on Console
right so these are ways in which these
companies can still make quality
products there smaller games 10 15 hour
maybe games the quality level in terms
of production value is still there and
the turn is still there because they're
not spending the money to Market and put
these things on stor shelves and all of
that stuff that they have to deal with
so it's it's a way forward that still
allows us the gamers to to get the type
of games that we're accustomed to
because that's another thing if all of a
sudden the game industry decided to be
like hey we're not making games that
look like the last of us two anymore
we're going to have a problem with that
we're going to have we're going to be
like yeah we're going to go back and
everything's going to look like a 360
that's not we would not be happy with
that we would not be happy with that
right so we they have to figure out a
way forward in that regard and it's
going short of games g and it's it's
love this AI oh and it's Ai and it is AI
and is like hey we going we going to
play we going to we we're going to pay
quote unquote Joe AI we're going to pay
somebody that understands how to manate
pushing AI so bad
like they they see AI as a way to you
know cut some of the other
things demanding and they're able to you
know use that to Captivate them and cut
some of the middleman out yeah and then
I'll give it right back to you s you
cooking um in reference to what adct
said about and the other thing is too
this is what I highly recommend and I
what not recommend but I think is going
to happen also as a result of this
because I know people say yo storm's
coming this looks bad it's e but the the
the good that could potentially happen
is to me what I call the circle of life
so you get people acquired what whatever
then some people leave get let go and
then they go do a startup and this is
when the we could get now the rise of
the startup and using tooling or
whatever it is to make to cut cost for
the new guy to get in and we are seeing
signs of that where you know archetype
Studio these are the former what is it
BioWare guys this studio these are the
former what you call it guy cuz people
are like you know what we can do it
ourselves you know what I'm saying and
have our own foundation for a business
as opposed to work so that that could be
which is what I'm hoping for I'm not
guaranteeing is but we got see but
continue say your points and I think
another thing that the industry is
finally starting to realize is like hey
we cannot follow Trends we cannot assume
God we cannot assume that's the biggest
issue in the
industry I think a lot of the reason
that some some of these companies are in
the situations that they are or W yeah
they they follow the trend
after the wave was over and you can't
see idea by time the game's done the
wave's over the wave over so it's like
you missed you missed it so you would
have had to come up the idea pretty much
at the same time that the popular
one Roy is popular and and be able to
capitalize on it or maybe or by the time
you come to the market even if the wave
is waning a little bit have something
that differentiates itself enough where
people will be interested and and you
become popular that way
but
it's but it's such when you think about
it I find it so weird that so many smart
business people jump on this and don't
and don't weigh the the the idea that
profit off they would get the idea of
how much you're going to
make so much that Co money was lit
it buy whole team make six but nobody
nobody had a force had to be like yo
this ain't going to last yo just just
the fact logistically we cannot get a
game out in time I get it to know that
it's this is still going to be popular
and we're going to waste all this money
on that it's just very weird to me that
it seems like a lot of companies didn't
see that so the idea now that everybody
seeing all of that play out right and
pretty much none of them being
successful at it and the big couple of
games are still a big couple of games
with a little bit of of penetration from
from new things coming in obviously the
power worlds of the world pause that I
got to get good sorry sorry power worlds
uh you know F future future world
killing game foam Stars you know he's
going to be out there doing his thing
but yeah pause pause on the
penetration continue continue sir I that
was King honor king would have looked at
me at that moment and we would have
laughed at each other definitely said
something for that yes yes please be
specific with where you withn
P be specific I I'm glad about that
really glad about that because it's
obvious that these companies are looking
at that like y we can't do this man you
know you know somebody looked at Jim
Ryan's you know road map was like nah
bro saying maybe Jim Ryan did he was
like no we can't do
this it's just like I'm glad about that
because again it's a return to a
normalization and seeing the industry
for what it is and where it is and
making sound decisions about the type of
games you put out there what the market
wants what the market will accept cuz
again I don't think the market will
accept like hey we can't give you these
you know these beautiful 4K games games
are going to go back to
1080p they going be 5 hours they just we
may not get that 100 hour crazy you know
that de Styles you know say I don't see
those type of games uh let me say
something um I'm sorry we still very
last thing and that is also why we start
saying that and and we talked about it
briefly earlier but hey they ating the
division that's going to be bringing
physical games about to we have the
leaks about Brooklyn and the All Digital
Xbox series X this is where they're
going and you know obviously slowly but
surely ever since the Xbox one
generation and the PS4 generation we saw
that more and more of the market is
leading into these digital purchases and
then we have you now you couple that
with services and and and and
subscriptions and things of that nature
for them they're going to save
we we're probably not going to see the
savings that much we'll see the $50 game
here and there the digital thing but for
them the importance is what do they save
on their end that can justify you know
them moving forward and not have to
worry about hey we're going to have to
lay off you know thousands of people
because we can't sustain this growth
that we had so it it's going to continue
to be painful and it's going to kind
continue to suck and something else will
probably pop up that that that causes a
problem as well but I do think they're
finally seeing the the forest for the
trees and stop having these dollar signs
in in their in their eyes and saying we
n it doesn't matter I don't care about
the pitfalls we can make it happen
people are are the per strings are a
little tighter now people making more
sound decisions I believe but it's going
to suck because it those sound decisions
are Sound business decisions means
people are going to go that's just what
it is wake up goad D WP up no I was just
saying what sa sa was saying he's 100%
right in my opinion um just the industry
we've been witnessing it right now you
know like you just mentioned the games
you know like Prince Of per a solid game
but it is a smaller game where the
previous Prince perses back then even
though they were two generations ago
they were still considered triaa games
yeah third person action third person
action adventure game so that's you know
I just feel that we as Gamers we got to
realize this is coming right we I mean
like there's some things in this world
we have no control over and I
believe digital um smaller games there
will still be games with great graphics
like a hellblade to but there are going
to be smaller experiences of course
there's still going to be the expensive
sports games you know those games
usually make their money back right yeah
annual releases those games will still
be there you know like the cods the GTA
those games will still be there because
those games are guaranteed right to be
hits but just me personally I feel we
are going to see less new triaa IPS
right big budget IPS yeah I just feel
yeah I'm they're going to be hesitant to
do those style of games I mean there's
going to be some games that still make
it but like a game that I actually
enjoyed came out 2022 the kalista
protocol I actually like that game
looked great great story I thought the
game was great game flopped flopped so
bad that the the company's pretty much
done right and no yeah I mean uh the guy
who worked on Dead
Space Glen Glenn scoffield left um and
started something else I believe the
game also which is crazy cost over $150
million to make 162 to be exactly what I
read yeah it's crazy man so yeah yeah
it's they got to figure it out yeah they
have to figure out they got to figure
out figure out unfortunate situation
again you know our heart goes out to
everybody you know who lost their their
position I you know for me on Twitter I
just try to signal boost other
opportunities for devs that are hiring
and saying that trying to get people to
land on their feet awful situation and
um yeah this is this sucks man this is
an industrywide problem and it's got to
get better this is just unacceptable in
my opinion for one of the biggest
industries one of the biggest things in
entertainment and we can't hold on to
our talent to me it's just that's my
thing I just I don't want our best
talent going to other industry yeah
facts facts especially how much we love
it but that's all we got we got a lot of
Super Chat St yeah yeah we got a few we
got a few all right all right I'm about
to get out of here man oh apprciate you
brother oh yeah get ready with the game
got your ready gold on I see you let's
go baby I appreciate you guys man gity
love thank you man peace out everybody
in the chat I'll see you guys tomorrow
on my show thanks again brother
peace all right let's see we have Danny
passion official $2 Super Chat oh my God
what a fight at the I don't know if that
means the beginning or the uh end of
Tekken a I'm sure both fights were Pro I
I the beginning one I think I did in the
demo I don't know that that that changed
but I'm sure the the end of that uh
story mode is probably crazy so but I
your camera turned off
what I don't know what's up with
that whoa okay can you hear no I still
can't just turn it on and off maybe
that'll fix it yeah okay give me one
second that was
weird
what happened his camera's off the
camera went
off yo it just turned off yeah I had you
back you
back it's back yeah you good okay I
don't know what happened now all right
uh let me see Lord Metroid $2 Super Chat
King is hanging out with Mikey bar the
Lost DLC
Jes yeah then we got J Boy On The Run $5
Super Chat giving the industry and the
other two companies the blueprint uh to
adjust to changes one thing Xbox Gamers
can say we will we will have say we will
have new experiences that is true that
is 100% true we got robot octopus 5
pound super chat I feel like Xbox and
Sony are in the game of All Digital
chicken PlayStation is just faking
supportting digital with a bolt with a
bolt on DD with a bolt on disc drive
they want Microsoft to take the heat are
you implying this is a goer situation
like a digital Xbox One
DRM do exactly this is how you share
games yeah they they don't want to jump
in 100% Xbox did the same thing with the
with the HD DVD drive Microsoft tends to
be very early with that kind of stuff
sometimes to they benefit or disant very
bullish very bullish yes sometimes to
their
detriment but sometimes it ultimately
does get proven later that that was the
right way to go and just that they may
have been too aggressive at the moment
too aggressive and early yeah yeah and
we got regie mobile 95 Super Chat salute
to the Lords in dirt great show we're in
the law indust we in the law industry
went through this in the early 2010s and
yeah we felt insecure all the time
layoffs facts yeah it's terrible
terrible in the building yeah and we got
Danny passion official $5 Super Chat my
wife works at a bank and the company
merged two years ago and they also had a
lot of layoffs until today the layoff
still continues without any notice yeah
yeah sucks yeah sometimes it's a very
slow process then we got senjutsu Sage
$10 Super Chat layoffs are terrible
there are however valid legitimate
safety reasons for abrupt notifications
due to mass uh casualty incidents the US
still has the world's best equipped Mass
murderers that is true and you never
know somebody come back and and light
things up you don't want that so I it
sucks because you can be you know the
bell of the ball one day and if you get
let go they treat you like you are a
stranger and that's just the nature of
it um and we got gamer by choice $5
Super Chat addict the other side you'll
tell someone in in in six in six million
you are laid off some people would try
to sabotage the company I'm going
through that now and it sucks again this
is why they take certain precautions and
and not tell people ahead of time it
sucks but that's why um then we got kid
Mo $5 Super Chat people made a big a
bigger deal than what it is last year
Microsoft laid off 10,000 in January 23
this just wasn't all that big in
comparison damn 10,000 wow I don't
remember I don't remember they they
probably I there were ton of layups last
year too probably maybe did I can't
remember yeah I do vaguely remember that
was it Microsoft or you mean Microsoft
like all of Microsoft I think yeah I
think they were layoffs last year then
we have Outlaw 21205 Super Chat it's
normal people that get laid off every
day just like this and ain't making
nowhere near as much money as those
developers are making that is very true
you know whatever it this is not to
justify it or anything like that but you
know hopefully Dev salar at a point
where it's like hopefully these people
have a little bit of cushion that allows
them to look without really falling into
a lot of financial issues but
devastating nonetheless yeah then we got
suitsu Sage again $5 Super Chat layoffs
are devastating and I feel for them but
companies also have a responsibility to
those who still remain and still work
there safety
first then we have Danny passion
official $5 Super Chat the conversation
should be about how many of these people
siding or part of what was happening at
APK the cleanup was coming yeah there
speculation that it was like okay they
took this had the opportunity to get rid
of any Bad actors at at Activision
Blizzard and we haven't really heard the
Fallout of that if that is the case from
people that are still there like hey
these people that were accused of doing
x y and z are now gone right you know
that would put maybe a little bit of a
better spin on some of this stuff but
still still
1900 other outside ABK and still yeah Z
ofx they weren't they weren't 1900
sexual
harassers
got to cleans the Great Purge the Great
Purge that would be crazy if you was on
that list exactly if it was that many
people there was way more stuff going on
over there than we
thought W that's a blizzard oh man Jesus
then we got wavy kosher member for eight
months uh Lord silver shout out to
everyone that's been laid off I hope
they find something better and more
secure I wanted to pursue development
but this past year has me wey that's
what I'm saying for all we know you know
we could get more you know top tier
developers more you know that that one
in a kind type of talent that comes
around every couple years but you know
they they probably they probably working
for for door dash sh behind closed doors
right now they probably doing the tech
side of that like talking to Neil right
Neil said story was sneaking in the e3s
hoping to get a job and then was it
Jason Rubin who we had in the real as
well you know
heason Neil told me like he took his
information he didn't think he was going
to call or whatever I think for
internship job you know what I'm saying
then looking what they so these are the
opportunities that help people get in
and if they're not available it's
getting harder to get in indry I would
be very surprised if a lot of the people
that's continue that's still in the
industry right now that after they see
that okay that's that's it like I'm I'm
looking I'm looking for something yeah
especially those who are affected right
yeah that's it deal with this um yeah we
got 774 in the chat with 34 likes hit
that like hit that like
button refresh your your YouTube
page desire okay still hit the damn like
hit the damn like Dam it um then we got
let me see Bay Area $5 Super Chat what's
up LS and my boy dirt hey Cog on ners
kick off in three hours for six will
prevail yes sir yes sir let's go
hopefully Debo in a building then we got
Mingo MC thickens $20 a CH for those
echoing frustration about the perceived
lack of empathy for those laid off
understand that this is life early in my
career I was promoted on a Wednesday and
laid off that Friday now I make over
140k I had to bounce back I mean this is
this is unfortunately this is a part of
life and I'm sure a lot of these people
are going to bounce back um but it's
it's hard it's hard when the rug is
pulled out from under you and you have
no time to prepare that's just tough for
anyone yep facts then we got GSD AKA
getting stuff done $5 Super Chat
everyone remember the interest rate
hikes all corporations have debt with
banks this is happening in lots of
Industries yeah despite being a trillion
dollar uh company there's debt
everywhere and yes sir and that's
something unfortunate but yeah that's
the the worker pays always yeah then we
have the professor with the $5 Super
Chat shout out to somebody whing out
today in the Bronx shout out that I hear
the cops I hear the cops always some
it's always an ambulance people why stay
home and watch football what are you
doing out in the
street all uh let me see $5 Super Chat
from the professor 100% confer or Co I
don't know if you meant to say Cog I
can't remember who but the pricing in
game never truly reflected inflation
like other sectors and a new model is
required Storm is Coming we've talked
about forever how we used to pay $80 for
games back in the day um as soon as they
got that battery backup in in Nintendo
games you're talking about $100 for a
game easily and nobody battered an ie
you were look into the the the Toys R R
circular and you would see these
different price games like damn what the
hell yeah Super Mario joints was like
100 joint is great inflation and like us
if we imported games forget it over
forget checking three cost us each
almost $100 each and we not going to
talk about how much play for import
PlayStation 2 we that's like a good
Jeep good and we got THX 1138 member for
two months Lord bronze game Crash of
1984 I was there so we one day industry
is booming the next week doors closed it
was wild don't want to see it again but
CEO
greed keep an eye out yeah you got to
keep an eye out for you know you have to
make bets that are sustainable yeah
especially if there's no pivots like
during the um over there and everybody
just maintain yeah you just remember
just just the dot bubble where everybody
had a and nobody had an actual physical
store to support what the dot was doing
and everything crashed yeah
then we got Sage once again $5 Super
Chat King is in here so I have to fill
the void when you guys say something has
to give for the games industry a crash
no but K&N sources say no
ps6 shout out to K&N sources king would
be proud king would be very proud Sage
you holding it down holding him
down now we have Sage once again $5
Super Chat it will see more new big AAA
new IP but mostly from Xbox game pass
limits risk and takes pressure off of
sales just grow yearly recurring
revenues well that's the Hope right
that's the Hope right and the fact that
they have the Minecrafts or the Kings
and all that that those projects could
help supplement the other stuff right
but again say you think about what AAA
thus far stands for in the Xbox space it
is you know it is a smaller outo world
it is a smaller of out it is a senua
that's you know seven or eight hours
right it isn't they're not doing that
they just there's going to be an
aversion to let's make a $100 game it's
just is what it is yeah yeah especially
I agree then we have Hollywood rules $2
Super Chat golden eye cost me $100 fact
facts remember them days CES no joke oh
my God that's it we're caught up on
super chats right now all right this is
me Tekken 8 get ready for the next
battle oh hold on Hollywood rules $2 you
said I pay $85 for Pat Riley basket
basketball with the closeups
bab my God salute yeah state of the art
technology state of the art baby so yeah
we here man Tekken 8 it is released
finally out there in stores lambco
currently sitting about a 90 Metacritic
yep still 90 Metacritic right now
reviewing very well super impressed I
just going to give my overall thoughts
obviously you know I've been you know
playing this series for over 30 years
that's crazy that's insan when you
reminded me of that 30 years of Tekken
and I've been there you know for for the
since the very beginning and um you know
it kind of started off as like a a a
knockoff virtue fighter clone that
wasn't really as good as virtue Fighters
but I like the limb system you know each
Button had a limb and all that and then
I would say Peak Tekken was probably
three is when they surpass I think three
is the yeah the Pinnacle of Tekken three
was Pinnacle now four was kind of eh
five got them back to go some people
feel five is the Pinnacle I just got to
be real like I know it early I I I've
done the story mode I've done the
campaign I've played a bit and there's
still a lot of things I got to do but
the way this is
projecting we could be talking about the
greatest Tech of all time it's that good
like first of all Unreal Engine
five har good Lord I don't know what
sorcery y'all doing you know when it's
crazy s MH we are at the point in Tekken
8 where the
ingame graphics look better than the
pre- runed yeah and I'm just like this
this is this is different like the the
facial animation it is just the effects
the backgrounds I mean the characters
are so distinct they ooze the
personality then I think on series X and
you know it's like 60 with you know 4K
60 but I'm probably moving down like to
1440 mainly consistent shout out to
digital founder they did the break they
said the The Edge did have the series X
on on the graphics that a slight Edge
there um doesn't drop no Lord at 1440p
consistent frame rate is sick um look
you know the music god tier music I'm
talking about usually every Tech has
about two tracks that are like super
standout this got about like nine you
know what I'm saying and then like as
you go through the story it is just
continually better and better you know
and they did it with the story mod I got
I got to give it up in the sense that
look
Tekken evolved the formula as far I mean
Tekken kind of set the trend where when
you come out with a fighting game you
got to have extras they pioneered that
they pioneered having endings in the
game different modes in the game Tekken
ball all this stuff right but when it
came and then each character had an
ending including the sub Ball but when
it came now to we get to like the Mortal
Kombats Mortal Kombat just takes to the
next level all the characters are
involved in the narrative Tekken finally
addressing this issue which is the
biggest elephant in the room with like
seven which it's like the budget seem to
be all with the Akuma story but it's
like no one else and then what are the
other characters doing if you're not a
Mishima you know what I'm saying and now
we have that full rostered kind of
Avengers like story you know what I'm
saying with with cin I'm not going to
spoil it but it's really good um I will
say this though there the Mortal Kombat
gang if y'all wouldn't say yeah that's
cool it still ain't messing with mk's
narrative that's fair as far as serious
realistic tone you know for the most
part what I like that Tech is doing is
they are going super anime and not
taking them themselves overly serious
you know what I'm saying they have them
more but yo this this it's something
multiple endings you know Tech Force
Mode plot twist dope charact like they
did that and then the last thing is you
know I mean not the last thing but um
the PVP aspect obviously playing online
now day one was woo spooky day one
little rough little rough little rough
we we getting we trying to set up player
mat matches and getting sent to
dashboard and I'm like oh not like this
roll back wasn't rolling back oh was it
was real spooky but the patch
immediately shout out to rod and the
team the next day boom functional
servers things were I I was very
spectator mode for everybody that's in
the so we could do the rotation you get
8 to 10 you could see who's private
who's not you know you want other people
online to come in the connection
everything Fant fantastic I've played a
lot of ranked online you know getting my
skill in the net code is strong that was
a probably with Tekken six probably the
net code is probably not the straight
that Tekken that Cod really been bass as
five to be honest you know what I'm
saying but nah that's really good now we
just got to see how the balancing works
out over time and the last thing I'll
just say is a game changer s you gonna
appreciate this heat all right heat is a
game changer for the aggressive cuz
remember old teeken dudes be turtling
they don't want to fight they want to
back they want a Korean back dash they
want to do all these movement not get
and their shots heat changes oh you're
going to fight cuz if that heat is on
you boss you are going to get chip
damaged away now that chip damage in
fish to the person who's being super
defensive and seeing their energy go
away if they start fighting back they
could regain some lost health so it's a
push pull to get people to get in the
mix you know what I'm saying so you got
that but to me the ultimate ultimate
game Cher which is going to take I wish
king was here for this
yo Tekken ghost
battle that AI is next level this is
where AI is I don't care what nobody
saying super positive for the industry
because let me tell you why the ghost
battles are so dope so let's just say we
all play it for the night right me you
Kai The Crew so let's just
say Kai or some what just really beating
you and trouble you with a specific
character whatever is all your matches
you was just having problems Tekken
automatically saves the replay of every
fight you go go to the replay section
right you could do two things first you
could like I'm going download cogo's
Ghost mhm I could download his ghost I
can how he fight with his herang I'm
I'mma put him in and I can just mix up
with him and it's AI doing all my
Tendencies oh I like the L Flamingo here
I like to start off the fight here I
like to like down to the science of that
is that's me right so they got the
moments down but here's where it gets
Next Level see how if I was playing
head-to-head Fighters yeah Co what me up
and down the streets I play Ai and I be
called that's how you doing it so the
thing was next levels besides the ghost
battles that you can do this fight
against all the people you've downloaded
and you can name them as a rival you can
do all this stuff but where it's next
level is the replay so now let's just
say so me and you were fighting right we
fighting Kai so you fighting Kai you're
like damn he's giving me problems with
his his gen right or his devil gym you
now go to the match watch the replay the
replay tells you during the fight that
you're watching yo s when you he was
doing that string all act was high you
could have ducked it stops it they
didn't let you enter the replay let you
enter the replay at the moment they
giving you the tips to then work on it
and fight in real time in the real play
yeah I didn't I didn't I didn't do all
of that yet oh my God BR the replays is
crazy then you could go back to watch it
rewinding fast forward it then they'll
even have things like all right see you
was blocking that you could have
punished him with this here are some
suggested moves so this is all about
getting people better you see what I'm
saying the ghost battle and
the is next level I wish king was here
cuz I was going to talk about Lord I
ain't Lord AI but I was going to talk
about Pro this is where AI could be good
for gaming right this is where a
situation where you like yo fighting
games need this like this is so next
level bro there was a dude online that
was tearing me up with Leo I was like yo
I can't he's he's with him he's doing
these stances he's doing all stuff if I
ain't download that man ghost
put it in and I was just do I was said
oh I can stop this is what I could do to
stop it now this is what he's doing okay
and then characters you unfamiliar you
know how it is when remember when Eddie
Gordo first came out you're like oh good
lord what to do there's characters like
that I see so it's it's such a Next
Level Jump For Fighting bro I'm telling
y'all right now look crazy champ is here
The champ is here I'm telling y'all
right that Tekken
man I'm just saying I'm just like yo
they they doing a phenomenal job they
really did it um I know it's early but
it could be the goat it could like it's
already feeling like that and it's it's
really good so highly advise if again oh
last thing if you a dude that don't play
fighting game you like nah son I can't
do this this what it is I'm telling you
right now I forgot about arcade mode
which is you make a literally Avatar
that looks like a little Nintendo Wii
kind of thing you make your man and the
game goes through a story mode of going
from arcade to Arcade and they have all
these characters teach you little
aspects of teken te you how to get up
how to use the new system like for
someone who's completely new you do that
and if you still suck at T you still
don't dad mode special Style special
style put the thing on one button and
you could get the combos out listen
Tekken still have fun y got it I know
it's early but as far as tekkin go yeah
this this definitely feel like the goat
level all those things you talked about
uh at the end at the end right there I
tried in the demo right I said I tried
the little arcade mode going you know
place to place and yes every time you go
to a different place you will get
somebody in the arcade showing you hey
let me show you this aspect of the
fighting of the system let me show you
what heat does let me show you all this
and it's a stepbystep way to get you
ingrained in there so that that to me
from the beginning I was like yes
because I know Street Fighter did it I
was like they need to figure out a way
to on board people in a way because
Tekken is is complicated game yes it is
it is simp there's nothing like that in
Mortal Kombat I would actually feel a
little bit more um like I would feel a
little bit more confident on
playing like Tekken or like online
because they have an aspect like that
like moral combat's like yeah you just
got to learn or just don't play play
yeah with Tekken um right the core of it
is simple because again you go back to
the whole idea of left punch Right Punch
left kick right kick that is the basis
for it that is it and then you can
combine make combinations of those to
get combos out grabs different things
and a lot of that stuff you can just you
can map to you know triggers and stuff
to make it easier for yourself but the
biggest key to Tekken has always been
understanding
distance understanding the pecking game
what they call okazi right the ground
game right the ground game the getup
game and understanding that for every
move that some somebody does there are
multiple ways to counter it and punish
it and it's a matter of you kind of
learning your own style what you like to
interrupt you not this is where it gets
Next Level you know the traditional Tech
is you go to your character then you go
to your move list in the move list
there's a separate count thing not only
just your move set for the character
also okay Punisher moves when somebody
keeps blocking you when someone does the
like they have scenarios and they have
scenario command list moves that tell
you when they use certain moons this is
what it's effective for that's different
for different scenarios in the fight so
now you like oh yeah I'm struggling
against somebody that blocks all the
time here is low this is what you do for
pressure here has a combo it it really
is helping the player but continue yeah
no no it to me that level of depth is
always been impenetrable for a lot of
people right we used to always buy the
Prima guy every time we bought the game
you buy the Prima guide with it with all
the move sets whatever and then we would
go into the dojo and we would just
practice learning the moves first and
then after learning the moves you play
against each other and you fig figure
out what works what works in What
scenario and that's how we learn to play
um but again the game was never really
so good at teaching you it it was good
at teaching you the moves and going in
there but scenarios and sort of teaching
you how to play the game and how to best
play the game it was always us just you
know figuring stuff out on the fly so
the fact that they're realizing hey for
the for fighting games to really you
know Elevate the way they were back then
and and we again with with with Street
Fighter 6 and MK1 and now this like
they're back baby they're really really
back game is back man Tekken is is that
highly recommend that's all I got unless
I got any more questions for me on the
game whatever well I just want to give a
little bit of my sure I forgot you
picked him about yeah I got it hasn't
played it but um so I downloaded it
initially on the raw cuz I wasn't home
to to play it any El so yeah I put on
the Ally um I saw like John Lan's
breakdown for the steam deck I was like
oh so the Ally is going to chew this up
like if the steam deck could get it to
60 the Allies going to chew it up and
yeah um honestly on default all I did
was drop the resolution down because it
defaulted to 1080p so I dropped it to
900 and I got that 60 and everything at
medium settings um and you know the size
of the screen means that you don't have
to worry you know about missing out on
detail it looks absolutely beautiful run
smooth Le so I can get my practice
on on the go Dojo on the go it's a
special thing but I went yesterday and I
downloaded it onto the shout out to NZXT
the NZXT player 3 AMD Edition that's
right salute salute let's get let's get
that link in the chat if we can let's go
let's go let's get the n60 up there but
I downloaded it there right and I you
know I just I downloaded it let the game
load up went into the game and I'm like
man it's a little slow like it's a
little slow so I'm like okay okay I
hadn't looked at what the what it
defaulted to I just I was a little slow
so I go in and obviously what it
defaults to is it analyzes your system
and says okay you could your system
could do this I go in if this game did
not default too yeah your system can run
this game at damn near 8K resolution oh
yeah 8 defaulted to it was almost 8K
resolution and I'm just like what the
hell and and mind you it was just a
little slow I was like it's one it was
still moving it just little slow it a
little slow I'm like oh okay dude I
dropped it to 4K M everything Ultra oh
oh my God are you applying I need to
test this out or no yes you need yes you
do I need to show you had to show my
build mhm yeah oh and speaking of show
your build we need to see we need to see
that that that Jin statue that your
special edition yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah we got that we got that out a shout
out to you know what I'm saying uh Dio
pad you know what I'm saying oh my God
hooking your boy up let me see that see
that crispy hold on let let's pin that
for a second I can't there we go boom
let's pin that that that kazaba you know
what I'm saying to do the light up joint
collector that's beautiful man sick Bro
this joint is crazy yeah shout out to
the snail killer that was beautiful yeah
so I did that I was like oh my God this
so this game like you know people
complain about unreal that there it you
there's hitches and it's clippy whatever
but this they got this engine singing in
this game unre five it it it is a sight
to behold on PC man it really is now I'm
playing a 4K Ultra with hdr on say yeah
yeah or it it is ridiculous and it runs
smooth as butter and like everything you
said they they added everything they
needed to it to be in line with you know
MK and to be line with Street Fighter in
addition to it just being Tekken and and
there's something very special about
Tekken you know it's it's that 3D space
um is one thing that I was a little like
I have to I have to get still get used
to right and for me from back in the day
it was like okay there was Virtual
Fighter as the most grounded fighter and
then there was Tekken to me where it was
like fell yeah the the the the moves who
grounded with you know within reason
obviously we were fighting against
pandas and you know whatever
but the mov set still felt relatively
grounded in like real marshs or whatever
right and that hasn't changed here but
like to like you alluded like the anime
of it has increased exponentially right
so there's a lot of
explosions devil jees everybody's on
steroids yeah yeah everybody work out
everybody everybody's working out
everybody beefy so initially I was like
yo it's almost too many effects while
fighting I'm like I some I can't even
see the moves that are coming
some kind of sparkling effect or
something like that so I'm like okay but
I as I ask Kai he says I can I can
adjust that on my end yes so I don't see
all of that and it looks like a more
grounded experience even though you know
it's online is playing out as as this
crazy you know bombastic experience
because to me that was the only thing
where it's
like for whatever reason like it it was
just it was a little it threw me off
because I'm like man I'm I I can't see
the move
it felt kind of like and I mind you I
felt this way when Street Fighter
started doing it right I was a street
fighter two purist just the super moves
you know Dragon punches and and and and
spinning kick and that's it and then we
started getting supers and I'm like okay
but they're just stronger versions of
their regular moves so okay that's fine
but you know Alpha took it in another
Direction you had like straight up super
moves and now you know in Street Fighter
6 MK you have literal like super moves
that are fullon like you know
pre-rendered animations or whatever so
um it makes sense that they would do it
in Tekken but it took a little bit of
getting used to in that regard but I
just love the fact they don't take
themselves too seriously in the story
it's kind of ridiculous and fun they
brought back so Tekken force is back as
well in addition to Teek so it's
technically back but like in a mode I
mean in in the game during the story
there's a part where it kind of comes
back it does it okay okay yeah so I
haven't done the story yet I went in
immediately and just I did King's little
story vignette thing and then I went
right into the dojo to practice so
that's what I've been doing so I need to
get the story mode done this week um but
man uh I I'm just I'm happy I didn't
really jump in on seven like that I was
I got it on Xbox day one I was excited
day one and I thought the game was good
I was a little mad that it was 720p and
it was like Blurry and I wasn't happy
with it so I just kind of fell off but I
I you know know I need to I need to get
my king back up get back in there I need
to get my Bri Fury back up um Tekken is
back and to your point I it's quite
possible that this is this could be an
all-timer because for me three was
Untouchable three was such three was
such an elevation of that formula um
speaking of games that we paid a lot for
we we we all got the import version and
we it was like 90 bucks 100 bucks bro
that game ain't leave my PlayStation one
all of us all and of us were playing it
on that not even the modded PlayStation
it was with the with the little eraser
holding the TR open um things we did for
Tekken Tekken means a lot to us so no
doubt so it's out there go check it out
and um highly recommend even if you're
not in the fighting games but that's all
I got let's add got anything we going to
move on so um s super chats before we go
yeah let's get let me a couple let me
see we got the black
john5 Super Chat the black John clear
not the white John this is the black
John be clear confusion yeah Tekken
currently has the longest running story
for a fighter MK and Street Fighter
can't see them that is true The machima
Saga is epic it's crazy them kids that
family is wow yeah then we got pixel bit
G $5 Super Chat peace Lords how does the
AI in teen hold up versus Killer
Instinct shadow lords mode and it Shadow
AI um I would feel I the fair this I
haven't really gone that deep with the
Killer Instinct one I would say that the
difficulty of Tekken AI on default is a
little regular so I would if you want
that real challenge I feel like probably
have to bump the difficulty if you're
like a seasoned veteran to attack in
bump it up but it's in the right spot
for people with new or just new to the
systems yeah I I went right to to Hard
Mode oh
damn n I'm not because you know it gets
easy you start grabbing people up and
you start if you feel that then yeah
that means you're vet you know they say
giving you exactly um but yeah I wish
king were here cuz King played a lot of
Killer Instinct yeah and I enjoyed it
superficially but I didn't really go
crazy deep into like learning it or
whatever which I should have because it
was a great game um but I don't know
about how good the shadow stuff is yeah
uh then we have Sage once again $10
Super Chat Sab is right but that's where
the genius of grabbing Bethesda and
other RPG teams comes in RPGs offer more
gameplay value Starfield Elder 6
Clockwork Etc XBox pick the future RPGs
that is true that is true and you will
get again with Starfield you will get
that you know whatever thousand hour
game right the but the bgs games you'll
get that I have a feeling that obsidian
isn't going to go too crazy in in terms
of making larger RPGs I think they like
the type of RP theyve literally said it
they they changeed the scope as far as
um the Outlook of what out but in terms
of they were going to try to do Skyrim
they like no let's get back to what we
doing what we do best yeah yeah H more
more condensed then we got Danny passion
official $2 Super Chat on PC the final
fight at 4K 60 is mindblowing yeah all
the effects like I said that that game
looked crazy oh my God and we got Don
Taco $5 Super Chat Tekken eight cool and
all but but when the new Smash comes out
it's over I'll see you in about a decade
Don the T that's when it's coming that's
how it's going to take for take out te
they going to Brak out ultimate again uh
for for thewit that's for sure super
switch they definitely will do that um
there we got Joe Repco AKA flame $5
Super Chat good afternoon ILP it sucks
to see Xbox have the biggest W this year
with power world and Then followed up
with the biggest L with the those leg
you know I didn't think about that it's
true they always find a way to step on a
rank somehow like L off man it's crazy
yeah I mean it was always coming right
they couldn't help it they nobody knew
the power was going to blow up that way
but it is funny like it's like sometimes
they can't ever have an extended W it's
always something to come out to somehow
yeah so hey whatever you know power
world is still out there eating crazy
yeah so we're cut up cool adct this is
you there's another game out on in these
streets on the same day that infinite
wealth was going on you could set me up
yeah well look it's infinite wealth time
let's see sh didn't I have oh no I do
currently let's refresh though currently
sitting at an 89 Metacritic and um again
came out the same day is Tekken 8 huge
reviews a lot of people saying a lot of
positive stuff this is the evolution of
the like a dragon series um ter based
now jrpg and of course Ichiban kazaka
the main protagonist was introduced and
then we had like a dragon gating which
kind of gave you the backstory for kiru
and now the team up in Hawaii so to
speak but uh a different different vibe
in the beginning so I want you to get
into what what you've played so far you
know what your thoughts on like a dragon
infinite wealth as a person who correct
WR like I got you into the series with
like a dragon the first one so this is
now your second one so what's your Fe
what's the
vibe I really you know first off I want
to be transparent I didn't play like the
the the game between like a dragon and
this the what was it called the man who
erased his name like a dragon yeah well
I I I forgot that name so you know I
went into this just with the knowledge
of like a dragon and I just feel like I
needed that so far no I I'm only
probably six hours in okay okay so I
probably need to go on I do think this
game is slow out the gate for some
reason and I don't think it's as bad on
people that watched and and played like
a dragon but if you're if this is your
first game into the franchise I think
you're going to like it less because
it's a lot of Easter eggs and like fan
service for the beginning cuz you're in
the same area from like a dragon and you
know you're getting a lot of that oh I
remember this place I remember that I
remember these characters but if you
have none of that knowledge yes you'll
be like are we really on this dude with
this date like really like like and it
shows you again how like how out of
touch ichib Bon yo has and always will
be bro he's such a goofball I love it
and what what I like is like it uh ichib
Bon's always like a dragon was everyone
is in the railroad but Ichi bom like
he's literally like a mental breakdown
and he his imagination he'll like see a
sword or people transform and what I
love how they handled the conversation
and the story is the rest is like this
dude's lost his mind go
yes like at the beginning when you
finally get to that point again and
they're like we got to get the bat out
and he he's just starts saying he's like
they transformed he's like oh and then
the people with you oh yeah that
happened last time just go with it he's
crazy it's fine so for clarity ichon
when you play the game when you're
fighting in battles he visualized his
favorite game is Dragon Quest so he
visualizes you see it through his eyes
as if everybody's these evil moners and
crazy characters and stuff like thattime
and what it is is yeah it is a it is a a
modern game that is the only way I've
seen pull a fantasy style without
breaking the modern yes play and it's
crazy how they do it like Ichibon like
he kind of belongs in a stray jacket
some way like he he really does he's
literally lost his mind like he he sees
he sees like at the beginning of a fight
they'll transform into other stuff and
ichib Bon's the only person seeing all
of this yes the rest of it like you
don't know what you're talking about fam
and since you're playing through ich
Bon's point of view you're seeing it and
but no one else is and what I like is
they acknowledge he's crazy no just go
with it it's cool like yes that's what
makes it fun he's like a goofy version
of old boy like he's been locked up
forever he comes out like he's all back
his mind is messed up and he doesn't
realize it it's no it's not it's not
that the pris thing it's just that he
he's such a he's like this dreamer gra
be gol lucky try
to and on top of that I view the world
like a video game okay so that he
literally sees the world that way yes
okay and what's funny is like the first
one you come across like this this bat
that's in the ground and you'll sit
there and you you go up to it and like
the other two can't lift it and then
he's the only one that lifts it and that
becomes ich Bon's main weapon game a bat
yeah and what's funny is like it's just
crazy I've never seen a game that kind
of has like that final fantasy fantasy
era but there they this game is clearly
in modern era but what happens is you're
playing it through someone that's pretty
much gone crazy and he sees all these
things and then everyone's just with it
yes oh no that's that's how it goes it
like every time they do a move that
would not be realistic in the world they
acknowledge that that's ich Bond it's
good we just go with it like yeah it's
like what with it breaking wall on
certain things it's absolutely hilarious
and to your point like the real real
world situations that's going on dudes
got to get dudes got laid off D getting
job situations is going it's just crazy
it's a crazy but continue so so where
you at with then as far as the combat
and did you you you in Hawaii yet yes
I'm in Hawaii okay you you you met the
you met the homie yet kir you the te-
went down yet no no not yet not yet I I
I've met a couple people uh I almost got
robbed oh you rob you touchdown oh no
yeah I almost got robbed it's it's it's
interesting like right now I don't have
the other people so I'm kind of curious
on like his imagination what's going to
happen when he runs into the newer
people and and like are they going to
have more of a back and forth because if
you guys remember in the first one like
it was a minute before they accepted
Ichi bonds just crazy yes like oh I
don't know what you're talking about ich
Bond so I'm kind of curious how they're
going to handle that happening again no
doubt what about the fighting system the
mini games they've improved it in every
every aspect now if if they're around
each other they'll they'll attack each
other as well you could hit people in
the buildings uh they they have
definitely you know improved this game
on every aspect Danny Patrick say no
spoilers we got you Daddy we ain't
spoiling we ain't spoiling we good no I
got you and then um I was going to say
Obviously the comment the turnbas do so
right now you got like a party with 3
four in in your joint or just it ity
still right now in just each well I'm
not going to I do have other people in
my party but I don't want to go into
that cuz that would be spoiling now how
we feeling about Hawaii as the setting
so far like you feeling this in that I
don't think I've played enough that can
really give like I literally just got
there no I got you yeah I'm in the same
Bo I mean I'm probably way earlier than
you I didn't get a chance I said playing
so Dam much damn Tekken but um and both
my favorite games drop on the same day
but we I got to say man I it's not often
that you have two games you're so
anticipating and they both hit it out
the park man like some sometimes man
yeah one of them fails you yeah no for
facts it usually never works out you
know especially you know these type of
games Tekken being a hardcore you know
fighting games sometimes the fighting
games don't pop won forget that and then
with you know like a dragon as much as I
love it you know Yakuza historically
it's kind of been this good series but
kind of Niche and not that critical and
claim but when my man came came ichan
kazak they changed sister to turnbas JL
G it's so good to see the critical
reception that it's now receiving in yo
they marketing is crazy right now that's
why like when people try to clarify oh
you know this is why Final Fantasy went
away from turn base it's like but every
modern turn base that actually took it
to the next level is all rating High
they're all selling well you got Persona
the what Persona 5 and Royale was like
an 88 Plus
yeah this game's an 89 the previous one
did well too so it's just like don't
give me that like they they wanted to
get as many people possible playing and
now uh you know games like 16 happen you
know that that's more of an action game
than RPG so yeah speak speaking of quick
marketing I'm going to change the
subject for a second did y'all see the
the Drone uh Tekken eight joint Tekken
eight over London Bridge how did they
even do that I have no idea that was
crazy that was buers I have no idea I
saw it on jez's time I'm like is this
real like this is crazy insane that was
insane yeah no I get you I mean then you
know obviously like a dragon Market has
been crazy they going over they got juw
SK ivly the Lords are part of it you
know what I'm saying see some of us on
that you see me on that but um yeah it's
just good to see to to your point like
the marketing for these type of and then
now they're getting the critical success
now I want to see if this actually
translates to sales that's going to be
big to see if it actually you know cuz I
know like a dragon really did I remember
rgg was very impressed with how it did
so to see how it is but go ahead add
I'll let you finish I'm hoping that it
did well and it continues to do well
because you know how like oh this is
turn Bas we're switching the combat yeah
you know we're not going to have our
expectations be as high as we normally
would for a game like this so I'm hoping
that you know just because the first
game did well now we want triple hold on
Triple this one the chat cover for they
don't like my listen I've made me and
ciru cool after playing
the man RAC so the KIRO slander has
calmed down but we not going to do the
ich slander saying that when my man came
the game actually sold we we're going to
put respect on ichiban's name as far as
popularity and Mass Appeal to this
franchise that wasn't selling with your
man was the leader so I feel you Mr too
opinionated and what's his name RG
shower the original shower posy 86 I see
you I see you gang gang and all that but
put respect on ich B for taking a series
look forward with the
sale I always got to get him a little
bit
continue you good you muted adct you
muted can't hear you yeah I hear you oh
there you go now now I can hear it's
good man I'm really enjoying it so far
I've been streaming on the addict Arena
channel uh so you know U really good man
so far uh solid experience uh I'm this
and Final fantasy rebirth were probably
my two most anticipated games this year
and about like those are the three like
trifectas that I really really want to
play this year and it seems like you
know hopefully all of them you know
deliver yeah give it a shot man this
this seems really cool I want so what we
ever be getting you in the world of
yakas in one day may maybe a little
little like a dragon infinite I mean the
fact that is is term based and it's you
know obviously Mission based like RPG is
something that I could consider being
able to play on the rck and like
dropping it coming back and forth so
maybe I didn't I bought the first one at
the laun to the Xbox series X I'm like
I'mma play this and that it stayed right
there bro oh that was a tie you supposed
to play it wasn't no real Halo infin
wasn't no major LA but you know what it
was like everything like at that point
everything started changing for me like
I had to work more and it was like same
happened with me like again I had my
issues with ff7 remake you know
Barrett's voice and stuff like that but
all overall I love that game um I had to
stop playing it because I just I I
didn't have the time anymore I feel you
and then I'm so far in that you know
that original playthrough on Playstation
I'm like man like I got you I want to
even though I you I could pick it up on
PC and and start it again on the on the
rag or whatever I'm like damn I'm so far
in that game I just need to find time to
go in and and you know take the half
hour it's going to take me to relearn
everything or whatever um but I don't
want to start all over again I got you
but this um I just again I heard so many
good things about this second one like
yo it takes the the formula it fixes you
know a lot of the things that people had
issues with in the first one uh you know
the same you know level of comedy and
and people really love this termbase
right cuz the original was just a kind
of a beat him up it was kind of in a lot
of ways the evolution of shenmu right
yes more action represents yeah so to
turn it into a straightup RPG and for it
to be received as well as as it has been
and to come come off of a character with
the history and pedigree of a kiru and
to be able to put another leading person
into that role it's a hard thing it's a
hard thing to do and for that character
to be endearing and be considered its
own thing and and not a lesser than
thing is is I Sega sega's they hot right
now they're doing their thing so um yeah
hopefully one day I I will get to play
it cuz I think I I would definitely
enjoy it the comedy aspects of it one
when I saw the men in the diapers I'm
like what the hell's going on what is
this summons pound mates hit the Fone
and wild people come out this people
come out and I heard there a Crazy Taxi
Driver in this his super is driving you
driving you till you want to throw up or
something like that they almost killing
you in an Uber then they got the mini
games like a Crazy Taxi on a bike
delivering pizza to people they like
sega's going on out vertu Fighters 3 in
it is a mini game like this is that's
right that's right you have all you have
all Sega game as well right you it's so
SGA like yeah shout to you would love it
because it's the spiritual successor of
how you know no disrespect to the OG
Suzuki you got be in the video games I
love you I'm not trying to SL you my man
I met you once you a hero but we got to
admit like where at was that like it
hasn't evolved since yeah yakaza is
truly what rgg is doing this is future
how it's supposed to be and and they and
they understand how to do a city and
moving things it's just so so well done
so yeah to see adct getting into it it's
super cool and the last thing I'll say
it's hilarious but this game will have
some of the most heartfelt moments when
you go yo the yakaza series has that
type of energy it's this nice balance of
silly goofy but also serious martial
Lords Gangsta Yakuza stuff going on so
yeah so I'm I'm with addict man I got to
catch up to him he ahead of me right now
heead of me but any other final words um
adct on Yak is a infinite wealth no I I
think I'm going to what I was going to
stream today but I think I'm going to
focus on other stuff today okay so I'll
be streaming tomorrow and I'll probably
stream it no doubt like a dragon
infinite wealth in stores go get that go
get that and we got one more time we got
the Super Chat let see yeah let me see
we got down Taco $2 Super Chat come on
you know Sakurai takes no breaks two
years Max yes we have joked about how
Zachariah is chained to the radiator
they don't allow they allow zachari is
there only to make Smash games so yet
never know it's
true uh let me see there we got Sage
once again $5 Super Chat Ichibon is
South Park to Stick of Truth style make
believe that's why these new Yakuza
games are so damn good yeah they good
man they good it's over the top yeah
then we got Danny passion official to
Super CH no spoilers please my wife and
I are playing it facts we got you we got
you kept it kept it clean yeah uh that's
it we qu up all no doubt final topic
solve this is
you somebody don't want to be Pals with
somebody somebody don't want to be Pals
with somebody um yeah so as we said at
the kind of at the opening of the show
pal world is taking on a life of its own
at this point it is easy to infer that
it is probably somewhere in the realm of
10 million copies sold 8 million as of
the 24th be no it could be who
knows that's not including Game Pass
purchases so the Game Pass purchases on
game pass through Early
Access elevates it to about nine and
again again we we'll probably get uh
numbers number one on PC get pass yeah
we're probably going to get more
concrete numbers come Monday right um
yeah so yeah so
obviously um the conversation around
this has been around the Integrity
around
whether the character models are too
derivative of of um of Pokemon uh you
know the company has come out and said
as much like hey you know this is how we
we did this this that and the other um
you know then but the internet sleuths
do with internet sleuths and they have
found that you know there may be some
sort of legs for for Nintendo to stand
on if they wanted to uh be litigious
about this but um and they came out and
said as much right Nintendo made a
statement indicating that we were going
to investigate these allegations of um
Power World possibly doing something to
infringe upon its IP in a way that maybe
they did not see beforehand because as
we said before um this game is it's no
secret this game was in development this
game has been kind of uh part of the
Mind share for a couple years now so I'm
sure Nintendo saw it I'm sure Nintendo's
lawyers looked at it and said maybe
there's probably nothing here that we
can sort of hang on to in terms of
litigation it just is what it is um but
again in recent days certain uh
Revelations that have come up uh
regarding the possibility of straight up
sort of what they call tracing of
literal tracing of models um and extreme
similarities with certain uh Pals in
comparison to certain certain Pokemon
has prompted Nintendo to come out and
say hey we're going to take a look at
this whether they do or they don't
that's still up for speculation but I
gotta say that you know and adct said it
it's like hey um once you start doing
this well no matter what the thinking
was beforehand you're GNA have more
eyeballs on your product and you're G to
have more in this case specifically
they're G to have more eyeballs eyeballs
on the genuinity of the product and uh
you know people out there defending you
know Pokemon and the Nintendo know they
don't want to see IP stolen um so yeah
it's it is possible in this scenario
that this comes back to bite the
developers of pow in the rear um but up
until now they've been eating they've
been eaten good they had to sit down and
have an emergency meeting with epic to
figure out uh the server stuff of this
stuff because servers are crashing cuz
so many people were playing um and I
think it's also pushed them to try to
really figure out a road map for this
game that is something that people can
latch on to and say hey this game that
we already think is pretty good um how
do we make it better how do we keep
evolving it because now you know borring
anything from Nintendo that shuts it
down right um this game has the ability
to take over the Zeitgeist in a way that
we haven't seen since fortnite pretty
much really yeah um so we will see what
happens there but again in total
probably close to 10 million units sold
in you know less than two weeks that's
insane y to he said they made it a hot
live power made in a hot song oh yeah it
did sure they crazy yeah so adct we got
you your your footage up of power while
you playing you know what's your
thoughts Nintendo made this statement
let me read the statement get let's get
the bars from Nintendo they said um
Pokemon excuse me Pokemon company excuse
me the official statement cu
we intend to investigate and take
appropriate measures to address any acts
that infringe on intellectual property
rights related to the Pokemon and they
said yeah they we we we've received many
inquiries regarding an another company's
game released in ch they W they won't
even say the name like the indirect
slander they was like we even see
against another company's game released
in January 2024 the Pokemon company says
we have not granted any permission for
the use of Pokemon intellectual property
or Assets in that game we intend to
investigate and take appropriate
measures to address any acts that
infringe on intellectual property rights
related to the Pokemon we will continue
to cherish and nurture each and every
Pokemon in its world and work to bring
the world together through Pokemon in
the future so they on the radar they on
the radar adct where where you
at now all that was is stop stop tagging
me on Twitter we understand
they have the game there's nothing we
can do about it just just leave me alone
like they they
threaten here's the thing you mean that
you expect me to believe that
they they shut down people that was just
sharing the mod for this game to make it
Pokemon but they can't do it to the game
and they shut that down immediately the
moment the moment you saw Ash and
Pikachu it was a so the they made
official Pokemon B on PC and Nintendo
got on them
quick almost immediately ceased
toist so they watching the shooters out
there oh who them gangs and ninjas y'all
fight who them who you uh they're called
The Syndicate they're supposed to be
Team
Rocket you can capture them you can put
them to work yeah you can but they're
allegedly Team Rocket team Rock okay
it's like these things that uh these
things took me out the first time and
what's funny is I finally got I finally
got guns like oh yeah gun it's l again
look how much damage this does man look
this is ridiculous I'm going have to
play this foolishness
man a sh why you why you Bing them like
that
yo ain't you supposed to get them low
and then enslave them yes that's what
I'm trying to do that's crazy well you
you got to capture them first before you
yeah you got to put you got to put him
in the work he look like a a good worker
so question adct the things that it does
similar to Pokemon like the capturing of
the pals and stuff is that better than
Pokemon do they do anything different
with it you know look the only the only
thing that resembles Pokemon on here is
just capturing Pokemon like creatures
like you know and I will admit that you
know this thing could probably be three
or four Pokemon in in in Nintendo's
world but it's like are we going to
start are we going to start like hitting
people cuz like okay the capturing
system is one thing but we can't just
start acting like people have creature
like that that's Pokemon like cuz in
that case did look breath of the wild
like I a going I ain't going to hold you
they said they have they've made a habit
out of cribbing of Nintendo game
properties so it's just like look like
at the end of the day you know I feel
them on that yeah but it's just like you
know Dam he bi to me what's important is
like it doesn't play like Pokemon and it
doesn't like you know Tim Tim plays more
like
get put him to work well I'm going just
throw another one at him if he escapes
so wait let me see where your work is I
want to see the the sweat the salt mins
you got going on where's your base let's
get to the Bas I want to see who you put
in the work who's not doing what they
supposed to do oh you got one of those
oh okay you just fly to the Joint okay
yeah so look this game look just the
dead bod Ling everywhere this game this
game plays more like Arc than anything
uh that that's what this game plays like
it plays like Arc and I understand like
here like my thing when it comes to
people are like oh you know Nintendo
needs to respond for what like they
didn't shut down Tim Tim yeah and I feel
like they had more of a an argument to
shut down Tim Tim because it was
literally
turnbas craftopia was craftopia was was
bread to the wild right so it was like
it's like we got to stop with this you
know we got to shut anything that even
remotely looks like Pokemon cuz you know
what that does that that doesn't put
Nintendo in a spot where they got to
improve because their fans are harassing
anyone that even tries remotely do what
Pokemon's doing you know what's funny
Super Smash Brothers has been copied
like six times we shutting all those
down too
like that's why a lot of the arguments
around here's one of my uh here's my
miny C oh oh you got the big turtle
backs they do they do your mind oh you
got them that's cool wait so they doing
the or what that's the or the IR you
getting them to work yeah that's how I
get and they put it in this box when
it's done that's what's up I I got to
say like all this all the conversation
around
like look yes it you look at it you like
yes you took serious inspiration from
this thing right but at the end of the
day like the law is the law so it's like
I could I could feel about a type of way
about it uh on a personal level and
think like hey you you guys are bankrupt
of like of having any real creativity
right
cast got a castle what's man right here
he's been building how many hours you
got in this ad I couldn't tell you and
then like the outside cuz I I built it
intentionally if like I ever can like
migrate this to a to a what to a a
server where the outside is complete
wood and it looks weak as hell but the
entire inside of the base is Stone like
so you'll blow like one side up and then
and then you have like way more Health
that you got to do no I feel I'll jump
in real quick if y got your' balls off
look you know I get it I I I feel
Nintendo on some of the creatures are
egregious I just say it egregious I will
say that some again is a little like
what HOV said like fly a little too
close to the Sun with certain
similarities of course but to proven
court is a whole another thing because
now you have to say that your game is
pretty much you know identically been
stolen and the problem is the components
of power like adct said is more like Arc
survival Monster Hunter with this one
aspect of the Pokemon catch and you know
the throw the ball kind of thing and the
fact that they've got again it's a 3D
game Pokemon is it Pokemon to turn base
I don't even play Pokemon isn't it
turn it's like it's going to be hard for
them now again like said you could so
anything they would have they they had R
uh room to to take court that have been
done by right so to me this wolf tickets
you just blowing smoke and you ain't you
you gon to go at the the the the the
creators that's trying to do mods I see
that I see you doing that but I'm not
there with it you know what I'm saying
because to me this is I don't think they
have a child because to me this is more
an indictment on Nintendo and Pokemon
because this shows me that your
community has been screaming for you to
do these type of things
and they haven't been doing it so now
everybody's like yeah we could beat up
Pokemons over their head ensave them put
them to work do all this craziness
mature stuff and survival and people
having fun you know what I'm saying and
I'm already biased cuz they got me in
the game what is it
C they got the bird with my name I'm
biased I'm in Pocket PIR I need a bag I
need a bag pocket PIR I would not
feeling this AI Renditions of the iron
Lord yeah listen listen manist don't get
mad Nintendo cuz they like as what my
man said they they took the line you
miss hot line they made it a hot song
and they fired I will say to adct point
and your it's funny that they talk about
it not at up to 8 to 10 million though
not at to 8 to 10 million now all of a
sudden you want to you want you want to
look at what's you want to investigate
what's I I personally would be shocked
if they do anything good business would
tell you maybe maybe Nintendo won't do
this because Nintendo obviously owns
part of the Pokemon company um but good
business would tell you we want this
game on the next Nintendo like smart
business I I am curious if they do try
to get this on their platform because
Nintendo is one of the few people that
could say no no they keep that they can
keep that it would be interesting yeah
it would be interesting I I can totally
see Nintendo be like nah that's yours
that we ain't doing that like I'm
curious because Nintendo is one of the
companies that they don't care about
business if they fill away yeah and I'm
wondering if they will take that that
far in terms of their business yeah
maybe that's the work I don't know it's
going to be crazy see I just play out uh
I'm I'm curious I'm very impressed with
what I'm seeing with power world people
absolutely love the game people that
give it a shot I played it I had fun
with it just too many games right now so
me for me to get back to it just yet but
no they doing it I just want to see and
I love that they got the road map PVP
raids all like they look like they're
supporting Xbox version going to get
supported more they're going to do
crossplay it looks like they've got a
good future and now it's going to be
curious to see what Microsoft does as it
continues it seems like it's a Dev team
like you know again all the stuff aside
where they take a lot of inspiration
from other particularly Nintendo games
it seems like they a very competent team
though in terms of putting out a product
that people like to play so um again
take the opportunity to to to Glow blow
this whole game out and and and give
them the bag yeah and because yeah it
feels like this is going to be around
for a while it even if it is a short I
don't I'm not saying it's going to be
Pokemon levels and get to that but even
if it it is a relatively short wave
there's a lot of Buddy to be made in
that in that short wave it does seem
like the company's taking the resources
they're making and they're and they're
they're doing right by their community
so as long as they keep that mentality
up where it's like we're not going to
blow money we're actually going to spend
it effectively and get these these
content out the way in a timely matter
and consistently update this game I can
see this being one of the biggest games
in a long time but it just depends on
how they handle success cuz some people
will get success and they drop the ball
yeah and and one thing that's positive
that I liked as soon as they've been
announcing if you look at the uh Power
car they've been announcing their
Milestones but what I like is they say
hey here's the role map we got but we're
not going to do any of this yet until we
address the core issues of the game and
fix them up and I like that they said
that would make more sense because
they're in the preview program where
they're like look we just keep this in
preview program and give you content
where you buy it and now instead of
doing that they're like we want the game
to be functionable then we'll build on
to exactly that's said again pocket pair
you're doing your thing salute now don't
have my lawyers come for you with the
Cognito thing so make it right IOP we
need a bag I need a bag I don't want to
have to S with intend on you on this one
so I'm not feeding that Latino rition
I'm not about that you'll be funny coito
needs a bag clearly I was inspired by
something those
I uh uh Pals end up in the game somehow
oh bro listen they can take off the IOP
listen I use do my corporate C listen
I'm need M redone first now we like you
we like Latino
Pals greasy Lao you a like your Latino P
was sweating like no I'm good B is extra
beefy B is Beefy I like my bad PA they
they they gave Cog like like a 12pack on
top of a sixpack on top of you had the
wolf pal you had the wolf Jo you look
like a Tekken character yes so look do
the right thing y'all got the right
mindset drop the bag off I support man
you going to get that we going to take
it to the next level we GNA get you that
that 20
Mill anyway let's get him out of here
man the iron
pal I'm done yeah your camera I don't
know what's good I I you know what I'm
hoping that it's my dummy battery that's
just dying dying out and then I have to
replace it because otherwise I don't
know what the hell's going on happens to
me it's all good real quick I don't know
how new this is or whatever breaking
news I don't know how breaking it is but
post up put something up like saying
that um visions of mana's Game Pass I'm
hearing those rumors it's been showing
up in a few places that's in game yeah
I'm hearing those rumors guys we got to
see maybe they just wanted to if it's
true it would be interesting to say hey
don't mention it now let's get the sales
up as you get closer but then how far
are they from the lease I forgot I
forgot when it's coming out it's summer
right I like that or maybe somebody
messed up and they seeing the internal
thing yeah but it's multiple places
where it happen so it's either that's
true or someone messed up like eight
different places s Enix experimenting
with the Game Pass back situation maybe
give the little smaller title a go and
you get other stuff as part part of the
package deal for dealing with us listen
I had this conversation with kin he
agrees with me he said K I think you're
on it on to something because he's like
generally how these companies work is
like okay you got to take for spoken you
got to take the new IP what he uncertain
about we ain't going to give you the
Final Fantasy 7 and all that just yet
that's later but you do all this stuff
for us then we give you the 16 then we
give you the Remake and you throw you
know Su of them in the game pass get
them from interesting they getting cozy
I agree lyia M getting cozy yeah but
anyway that's all we got L Super Chat
let's get up out of here uh let's see we
got a couple let me see we got black
Ronin 357 $5 Super Chat Nintendo better
keep shut Les someone pull the Dragon
Quest out oh everything that's been
pulled out on the on this has been
debunked so far so yeah again listen as
many people out there trying to to prove
guilt there people out there debunking
it right so it's interesting scenario
out there very interesting then we got
Simple Jack $5 Super Chat guy that made
those mesh comparisons admitted to
stretching the truth and that they
weren't one to one so there you go there
you go and that's that's the part you
got to prove yeah that's the part you
get approv exactly there we got Donald
taku $5 Super Chat the capture mechanic
and the bonus for capturing multiple of
the same type is straight out of Legends
of archus and the crafting is equal to
Arc and the traversal is breath of the
wild yes I agree I agree it's an amalgam
of all those things then we got doaku
again $5 super chat but unlike which
hasn't been surpassed power world is
lapping the latest Pokemon by m wow
that's that's gangster that's gangster
now we got to got to respect power
world's name right now it's because like
the Pokemon formula fits very well in a
survival type of game it does and it's
hard to make those Super Smash Brothers
games I honestly think the platform
holders could do it correctly but you
know you I think especially Microsoft
how many characters can Microsoft use to
to this point now at this point they
could use a whole lot
I always thought it would be cool if
they they work with Nintendo and they
have Nintendo make three versions of the
game and they're all crossplay and you
can't play with Nintendo what characters
but when you go online and you play
someone on Xbox but through crossplay
it's their characters versus Xbox
characters that' be crazy man sick
that's it we'll CAU up nice nice and
then we got zip hole to get up out of
here um yeah with all the recent layoffs
with their Microsoft gaming division
which to you was the most surprising the
choices are a blizzard leadership
departures B other Xbox and zenax
layoffs C physical media and odyssey
team or D I don't care don't think your
favorite game company isn't next those
are the choices go Rock the vote send
some love to Lord King David going
through some little technical te issues
right now hopefully we get the king back
we all he he's mad he wanted to be he we
thought he still could make it cuz he
had got an ETA or maybe when the things
get resolved but unfortunately not this
week get it back hopefully next week
that situation shout out to Hip Hop
gamer shout out to Dirk GGY pulling up
in the realm holding us down you already
know Lord addict where can to find
people find you what you got going on
you can find me on Twitter at Lord
addict IOP you can find me on YouTube at
gaming addict also uh my streaming
channel is adct Arena I'll be
streaming probably teeken eight
unfortunately ad Arena that's where it's
supposed to be let's go yeah I'm going
yeah let's I want you do that story
that's what I want I want that story
done then we going to get the
competitive going on yeah you going to
be in a rotation yeah someone going have
to hit up my PayPal for all that oh we
got to be
robed yeah oh man you can also find me
on
um uh that's it we a't going to find you
nowhere else huh that's it all right
cool yeah that's it no doubt Lord s we
can find people find you what you got
going on sir you can find me on Lords I
on Twitter and hopefully hopefully
playing some uh Prince of Persia and
Tekken this week get back to Prince of
Persia but that Tekken once you when you
get into the dojo and it's like man I
gotta I got to make sure I got this man
right cuz these these guys Savages out
here got to stay sharp out here these
boys are crazy and the reflexes are not
what they once were so we got to got to
prepare no doubt no doubt yeah man again
salute to everybody pulling up in the
realm good to see y hit that like button
on the way out more fun stuff playing
good stuff next week adct anything else
we got to promote we good uh that's it
all right no doubt everybody enjoy your
Sunday we catch yall let what's up I say
who we who we sending today we s oh we
got another got another one in oh I got
it yeah got it we actually got oh we got
we got Craig hooligan gifted one IP
membership shout out to you bro put the
question in the chat now we got Sage $5
Super Chat sorry Cog we need to the
stream to run till at least 10 to 11:
p.m. past 6:30 p.m. no particular reason
but I can't go against Eminem too big a
you riding with all right I see what you
say we a this this show over I'm more
watch this game I got what's going on
the first gate and the second game
that's all we got y yeah sending you
guys over wandering Dutch he's over
there playing power right now oh yeah
dut love IOP raid I want to see some IOP
raids in there you already know
everybody enjoy your Sunday
[Music]
peace